[Musique]
14 heures sur les chaînes parlementaires
bonjour vous êtes sur public sénat
bienvenue à vous nouvelle émission des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
vous connaissez le principe lille est
simple les sénateurs dans une heure vont
interpeller le gouvernement sur les
grands sujets d'actualité et nous avec
notre équipe de journalistes on va
essayer on va vous faire vivre ce moment
au plus près avec nous aujourd'hui vous
allez le voir cette belle brochette
jérôme rabier et là où tout se passe il
est dans l'hémicycle bonjour jérôme
donnez nous le programme un programme
varié steve ans on parlera du coc vidé
de ses conséquences du possible retour
de la réforme des retraites devant le
parlement ou encore de l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage prévue au 1er juillet mais au
lendemain de la gifle reçue par emmanuel
macron en déplacement dans la drôme
gérard larcher le président du sénat
prendra la parole en début de séance
pour une déclaration solennelle à ce
sujet et on suivra ça en direct merci
jérôme cantin est aussi avec nous quand
un calme et en salle des conférences à
quelques mètres de l'hémicycle quentin
vous faut réagir des ministres et les
élus
bonjour style bonjour à tous survécu
retrouvé depuis la salle des conférences
du sénat effectivement à nos micros dans
quelques instants des présidents de
groupes politiques du sénat viendront
réagir
à ce geste cette gifle adressée aux
produits qui errent dans la drôme steve
merci beaucoup canton et puis on
retrouve cette semaine jean m'assieds sa
communauté gens ravis de compter à
nouveau parmi nous raconte nous sur la
plateforme twitch de quoi on parle
aujourd'hui
et oui bonjour steve et bien écoute on a
on parle beaucoup évidemment de la
réouverture des bars des restaurants la
reprise des salles de sport mais aussi
beaucoup de l'événement d'hier la gifle
reçue par le président la république qui
tu t'en doutes fait beaucoup réagir les
internautes merci vous gens à tout à
l'heure
au programme de cette première heure
cette question cette question qui agite
encore et toujours les débats au
parlement
la pma pour toutes les femmes faut-il
oui ou non l'autorisé c'était on s'en
rappelle une promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel macron ça devrait être la
première grande réforme sociétale du
chef de l'état mais ici au sénat la
question divise toujours autant ça sera
l'objet de notre face à face et à 14h30
ce sera avec le sénateur lr dominique de
legge et la sénatrice socialiste michèle
manière
mais d'abord mais d'abord on va parler
business et finances publiques depuis
quelques jours tout le monde en parle
sept pays parmi les plus riches de la
planète dont la france ont annoncé le
week-end dernier s'être mis d'accord sur
un impôt mondial c'est inédit c'est une
première les bénéfices réalisés par les
multinationales à l'étranger pourraient
à l'avenir être taxés à au moins 15 %
alors cette réforme va-t-elle réellement
voir le jour est ce vraiment la fin des
paradis fiscaux comme on l'a beaucoup
entendu pour en parler quatre experts en
quelque sorte de ces questions avec moi
en plateau aujourd'hui éric bocquet
bonjour bonjour ans sénateur communiste
du nord avec moi également en plateau
jean françois husson bonjour bonjour
sénateurs l ère de la meurthe et moselle
et puis également avec nous en visio
isabelle this-saint-jean bonjour vous
êtes économiste secrétaire national en
charge des études au parti socialiste et
également avec nous en visio agnès
verdier molinié bonjour vous êtes
directrice de l'institut ifrap vous avez
signé en janvier 2021 ce livre la france
peut-elle encore tenir longtemps c'est
paru aux éditions albin michel bonjour
merci d'être avec nous alors avant de
mettre les pieds dans place si vous
voulez bien on va mesurer un peu le
parcours qui reste à faire avant que
cette réforme voit le jour regarder ce
sujet il est signé marion delpech
c'est un pas de géant la naissance d'une
taxe mondiale pour les multinationales à
l'issue d'un sommet de deux jours à
londres les ministres des finances des
pays du g7 ont voté un accord pour
mettre en place une taxation mondiale
d'au moins 15% sur les bénéfices des
entreprises
un accord jugé historique par le
ministre des finances britannique et par
bruno le maire c'est un accord
historique
pour la première fois depuis des années
les états membres du g7 sont capables de
définir des règles pour le système
international du 21e siècle un accord
encore inimaginable il ya quelques mois
donald trump avait torpillé les
négociations l'équipe de joe biden et sa
secrétaire au trésor les ont remises sur
la table si le projet de réforme est
unanimement salué le niveau du taux
proposés fait lui débat comme
l'expliquent la responsable de
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques
c'est un dock est quand même extrêmement
bas et c'est un taux qu'on a fixés pour
ne pas s'attirer trop d'opposition que
ce soit de la part des entreprises des
multinationales qui sont concernés ou de
la part des états qui appliquent des
taux des taux très bas et qu'ils sont
vraiment des acteurs de la concurrence
fiscale
il est clair que somme toute ça reste un
tout qui est très éloignée des taux
pratiqués dans nos grandes économies et
donc des taux que subissent les petits
entrepreneurs les commerçants qui eux ne
peuvent pas délocaliser leurs activités
profiter de taux plus bas
le texte prévoit une autre mesure
spécifique aux multinationales hyper
bénéficiaires comme les géants du
numérique dans les pays où ils gagnent
de l'argent
ils devront mettre davantage la main à
la poche une étape politique nécessaire
mais pas suffisante
cet accord devra aussi être adoptées par
le g20 le groupe des 20 pays les plus
industrialisés qui se réunira en italie
le mois prochain
erin bloqué vous y croyez vous à cette
réforme elle va vraiment voir le jour
bah écoutez moi je me remémore 2009 le
g20 de pittsburgh où un ancien présent
la réplique française avait décrété ex
cathedra la fin des paradis fiscaux
nicolas sarkozy voilà c'était il ya
douze ans et depuis je vais pas énumérer
l'immensité les scandales qui ont révélé
l'existence et le développement de
l'évasion fiscale dans ce sur cette
planète luc slicks la sphère cahuzac ubs
hsbc etc etc
donc tout cela continue edvald plus
belle donc là la petite nouveauté que je
prends en compte quand même c'est le pas
en avant des américains qui a changé un
peu la donne merci joe biden la
cinquième jeu effectivement merci job
mais déjà il en a rabattu un peu
puisqu'il ya deux mois il a annoncé 21%
et là on démarre les discussions avec un
taux de 15 qui effectivement de
tourments insuffisant mais je suis son
cette réforme
vous y croyez vous quand est ce que les
multinationales vont passer à la caisse
2025-2030 ça prend du temps en tout cas
non mais je donne d'abord je pense qu'il
faut il faut saluer la décision
aujourd'hui
cette annonce et samedi on est déjà en
train de critiquer un premier pas moi je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent et dieu
sait si on n'est pas tout à fait de la
même sensibilité politique avec reebok
et je pense que c'est une décision qui
doit marquer alors qui pour moi qui
entre dans l'histoire y est de marquer
finalement à la fois un objectif de
solidarité et de justice fiscale et donc
quand même de poser ce cette base
aujourd'hui de discussions à l'échelle
planétaire c'est pas rien je compare
juste la france jusqu'à présent
notamment par l'intermédiaire de son is
l'économie et des finances
se battait avec ses petits points mais
avec volontarisme pour la taxe gaf a là
il ya une ambition qui est plus grande
ne demandez pas en deux coups de
cuillère à pot de trouver ex abrupto la
solution qui convient à tout le monde g7
et g20
il y aura un deuxième temps le gvt à et
orale ocde il faut pas facile le cd ans
et non mais il faut un peu de temps et
puis on verra chacun va devoir aussi
montré dans quelle disposition d'esprit
dès qu'elle est avec quel entrain et
puis je pense qu'il faudra jouer
collectif pour ce que des majorités se
décide elle emporte l'europe
à mon avis va voir aussi une en place et
un rôle important à jouer on va revenir
effectivement sur l'europe mais avant ça
j'aimerais vous entendre agnès verdier
molinié
après quarante ans de baisse d'impôts
sur les entreprises c'est un changement
de paradigme goûté on peut pas être
contre un impôt minimum
la question c'est comment on va calculer
ce taux de 15% et pour l'instant c'est
pas très très clair il ya une
quarantaine de pages dédiées à la
formule de calcul dans les documents
préliminaire de l' ocde
et vous savez quand on regarde les taux
affichés et puis des taux effectifs et
puis des taux marginaux effectif c'est
pas toujours la même chose par exemple
en france on a un taux effectif qui
était en 2019 de 30,3 c'est en train de
baisser un peu le taux marginal effectif
il est de ces sept voiliers et c'est
toute la question c'est comment ça va
être calculée visiblement il va y avoir
de l'impôt sur les sociétés mais aussi
l'équivalent de la cvs
la taxe sur la valeur ajoutée qu'on a en
france qui en fait un taux de production
tu as une taxe sur la production donc
tout est encore assez opaque sur la
question de comment on va calculer ce
taux de 15%
il faut faire attention parce que on a
aussi beaucoup de pays qui sont
exportatrices qui peuvent avoir par
exemple des crédits d'impôts sur la
recherche sur le crédit impôt recherche
qui peuvent bénéficier de finalement
d'un co qui sont à minorer parce qu'ils
investissent dans la recherche parce que
ils ont fait un moment des déficits qui
sont reportables
et il faudrait pas qu'on se retrouve à
taxer beaucoup plus nos propres
entreprises françaises quand elles sont
exportatrices quand elles sont
développées internationale et pourtant
qu'elles sont juste de très grosses pme
donc nous attendons de voir comment ils
devront être calculées les tous
exactement
est ce que ça va donner derrière il faut
pas oublier que nos entreprises elles
sont pas taxés comme l'impôt sur les
sociétés un mois je m'intéresse surtout
à la question la france aux entreprises
françaises comment les développer on
sort une étude à la fondation ifrap on
montre qu'on a un niveau d'imposition en
france qui est de leurs 250 milliards
supplémentaires par rapport à la zone
euro
donc attention à ce que y est pas un
effet boomerang sur nos propres
entreprises
on va en reparler isabelle this saint
jean vous êtes d'accord avec agnès
verdier molinié l'impôt mondial pourquoi
pas d'en pratiquer bonjour les problèmes
alors un impôt mondial
évidemment fin c'était absolument
indispensable il faut bien voir quand
même que on avait depuis le début des
années 80 un mouvement d'érosion liés à
la mondialisation et la mise en place
des multinationales et des stratégies
d'évitement fiscal les multinationales
et donc on a eu un effondrement quand
vous regardez les chiffres ans et une
division par 2 entre le début des années
80 et aujourd'hui des impôts payés par
ces multinationales
ou alors que effectivement les
entreprises les pme les tpe elles sont
sur des taux tout à fait différent
auquel il ya vraiment et l'histoire
d'injustice
il ya une histoire de du coup rebord de
la fiscalité sur d'autres acteurs voire
une un effet de baisse de la capacité de
la puissance publique à agir et en
particulier dans un moment comme
aujourd'hui qui à un moment où il ya une
urgence à agir sur l'investissement
public sur un certain nombre de services
publics aux moyens qui sont à bout de
souffle en la santé la justice
l'université la recherche d'un bon aulas
ont je crois que tout le monde en est
convaincu à la sortie de la crise
sanitaire
et donc c'est tout sens c'est à tout ça
qu'il faut mettre un coup d'arrêt et
cette décision porté par wendel est
effectivement une très bonne nouvelle
une très bonne nouvelle maintenant
effectivement il faut voir si on va
jusqu'au bout et les négociations sont
pas finies et hydro que ça peut toujours
capoter sachant que alors attention il
ya des travaux qui ont été faits par me
gabriel lippmann connaissez probablement
qui est un économiste français qui
travaillent et qui travaillait aux états
unis j'avais été un peu à l'origine de
toute cette histoire
évidemment de cet impôt ceux de cet
impôt de plus dans les tailles mais
j'aimerais qu'on aille dans le concret
si vous le voulez bien ici à présent
jean-françois ils sont comment cet impôt
mondial pourrait se concrétiser sur le
terrain pour une multinationale
française m'a d'abord entré ce que ça
implique hama le d'abord yayi à deux
piliers
je le redis en france on était parti
plus tôt sur ce qu'on appelait la taxe
gafa qu'on voulait mondialisée donc
c'est plutôt le numérique
là on s'aperçoit que ce sont les
multinationales des multinationales y en
a qui sont évidemment et c'est bien sous
pavillon français
ce qu'il faut ce qui paraît naturel
c'est de lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux le dumping social et fiscal
et donc il va falloir s'entendre sur le
ce qu'a dit agnès verdier-molinié
c'est-à-dire l'assiette fiscale
et puis vous allez voir on va devoir
rentrer un peu dans le détail parce que
selon les pays et c'est là où ça va
penser à notre les niches fiscales
non mais je pense qu'il faudra enfin moi
je veux à ce stade
d'abord faire confiance à la capacité
des acteurs parce que il y aurait rien
de pire que d'avoir une annonce sans
lendemain ou sur laquelle on se battrait
je crois que c'est aussi l'intérêt
antrim et des grands pays de donner une
direction et après de venir travailler
ensemble mais immanquablement ça va
amener et alors dans l'exemple de la
france
bien évidemment notre système fiscal il
va falloir derrière leur travail et
leurs pensées le faire évoluer
parce qu'on a besoin pour créer de la
richesse et pour créer aussi de l'emploi
d'avoir des entreprises en bonne santé
qui rayonne sur le monde et qui emploie
en france on parle de
réindustrialisation par exemple si on
veut être fort il faut des règles mais
c'est plus facile quand vous avez des
règles qui sont communes que quand vous
jouez
j'irai où pratiquer le même la même
activité mais avec des règles
différentes voies ya du boulot quoi éric
bocquet ça va renflouer les caisses
publiques salle et on n'y est pas encore
là vous dites il ya du boulot
effectivement moi je pense qu'on engage
à marathon 42km on a fait les 100
premiers mètres avec cet îlot rêver il
faut il faut non seulement il faut rêver
mais il faut pour cela il faut lutter
faut se mobiliser et ça concerne
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
quand on regarde les modalités pratiques
déjà 2 2 c'est pas un traité qui a été
annoncée dimanche on a fait beaucoup de
communication communication maximum
d'imposition minimum mais les modalités
sont les suivantes
la taxation s'appliquerait aux
entreprises dont le la marge
bénéficiaire dépasse les 10 % d'accord
et on prendrait la taxe s'appliquerait
aux 20% supérieur à la marge
bénéficiaire de 10 % des jeunes pour y
échapper entre autres les jambes on en
rabat un peu un bon et puis comment
dirais-je après moi j'ai entendu la
réaction du premier ministre de la
république d'irlande qui dit nous avec
cette taxe on va perdre 2 milliards de
je doute que l'irlande ne se signent cet
accord aujourd'hui les juges viennent
justement va voir un peu ce qui se passe
ailleurs et notamment en europe on va
retrouver quand un calme mais qui est en
salle des conférences quentin vous êtes
avec andré gattolin je crois à la tout à
fait en 10 14 sénateurs r&d pays c'est
le groupe en marche ici au sénat
également vice présidente de la
commission des affaires européennes
ici au sénat lors un mot sur cet accord
qui était signé ce week-end est ce que
vous dites merci joe biden c'est lui qui
a visiblement pesé en faveur de cet
article dans cet accord n'est ce pas le
soutien des etats-unis a été déterminant
et puis devront en entraîner d'autres
notamment du japon de quelques grands
pays occidentaux
à l'origine c'est une demande de l'union
européenne
et c'est un dossier qui est porté depuis
des années je me rappelle quand j'étais
à la commission des finances
on avait des réunions avec le cd eux et
avec monsieur saint-amand qui
travaillaient sur ce dossier là
maintenant un accord politique a été
trouvée je suis d'accord ce n'est pas un
traité le travail reste à faire
mais son annonce est importante et
surtout à la base il va avoir un rôle
important dans la l'éradication je
dirais des paradis fiscaux
mais justement il ya les paradis fiscaux
au sein de l'union européenne à 27 pays
est-ce que vous avez vous pensez qu'il
va y avoir un accord facile à trouver
entre tous les pays membres
alors c'est toujours la difficulté parce
que les questions fiscales relève de
l'unanimité
bon les trois principaux pays concernés
les pays bas l'irlande et le luxembourg
ont réagi plutôt modérément mais sans
hostilité totale parce qu'ils se rendent
bien compte quand même qu'ils produisent
de la valeur sur le dos en fait de la
valeur qui est produite dans le reste du
continent européen
notamment dans les pays les plus
importants comme l'allemagne la france
l'italie ou l'espagne
un mot sur ce taux 15 % c'est un taux
plancher
il pourrait être plus
lever certains au parlement européen
aurait préféré un taux de 20% alors est
ce que vous dites
bruel bruno le maire et à certains de
ses homologues européens de s'emparer
aussi de cette question plutôt la
question du taux est importante mais
elle reste ouverte
elle va pouvoir progresser et c'est
l'intérêt aujourd'hui des états avec
l'endettement que tous les pays même les
plus riches ont subi avec la crise du
coc vide
donc il faudrait trouver de l'argent le
plus important et le plus déterminant
ça va être vraiment la répartition de la
valeur vous prenez les états unis vous
prenez ce qu'on appelle les gars femmes
les géants du numérique
la loi fiscale de 2017 qui a été engagé
par donald trump a augmenté
singulièrement leur âme peau et leur
bile ya obligation de rapatrier leur
bénéfice aux états unis co vont dire les
états unis quand on va dire nous nous
voulons notre part sur la valeur
produite par google en europe alors
qu'ils sont déjà taxés à plus de 25% aux
etats-unis
c'est là où le travail commence à mon
avis on va vers d'âpres négociations et
malheureusement et comme toujours des
compromis mais si ce sont des compromis
qui vont dans la bonne direction
eh bien profitons-en c'est mieux que
l'état actuel qui est profondément
inquiétant merci beaucoup merci andré
gattolin d'avoir accepté de réagir à
notre micro his three merci beaucoup
quentin agnès verdier-molinié il va
falloir convaincre l'irlande de relever
son taux d'imposition comment faut s'y
prendre
c'est pas gagné d'avancé mais je
voudrais réagir est ce que vous avez dit
toute heure est ce que tout ça ça va
renflouer les caisses de l'état français
s'est pas du tout sûr parce que d'une
part ça peut renflouer
parce que et on peut récupérer c'est
vrai un peu d'un côté pour ceux qui qui
finalement vendent en france mais
d'autre part pour les entreprises
françaises qui vendent à l'étranger
celles qui sont au-delà de 20 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires depuis de 10% de
marge ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure et
bien celle là elles vont devoir votants
ciel ou pas payer dans d'autres pays et
c'est autant qu'on va potentiellement
perdre aussi pour le trésor pensez donc
tout pas du tout crier victoire parce
que on a des entreprises dans le cac 1
par exemple ans a été cité dans la
presse lvmh air liquide qui vont être
concernés par cet impôt mondial
et là ça va être des pertes pour la
france donc il faudrait bien faire les
comptes des deux côtés et éviter de
jouer la politique des bisounours en se
disant ça absolument nous rapporter
cette passion du tout parce qu'on a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont des
entreprises installées pour leur siège
dans notre pays mais qui vendent et qui
sont beaucoup finalement dans la
production et dans la vente à l'étranger
et là ça peut poser beaucoup de
questions sur ce que ça va vraiment
permettre de récupérer au niveau du
trésor français
donc plutôt que de se poser toutes ces
questions de comment re a convaincu les
autres pays déjà faisons le bilan de
comment comment dans notre pays
ça va avoir
impact sur les recettes publiques sur
nos entreprises et je trouve qu'à ce
stade on est beaucoup dans la
communication mais pas beaucoup dans
l'étude d'impact et dans l'évaluation
cette annonce de cet accord du g7 en
tout cas suscité et suscite on voit
encore beaucoup de réactions de
commentaire parmi ces réactions je
voulais vous faire écouter thierry
breton commissaire européen au marché
intérieur pour lui cet accord rebat
complètement les cartes époux tcd sur
rtl
c'est quand même une avancée extrêmement
significative parce que ça veut dire
finalement quelque part la fin des
paradis fiscaux quoi il faut il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont et ça
c'est quand même jusque là vous me
disent ah oui c'est la wii
automatiquement parce que chaque pays va
avoir maintenant une obligation de taxer
à minima à minima je dis bien parce que
c'est peut-être qu'on le ça montre un
peu le 15 pour cent donc les entreprises
qui exercent une activité qu'on prenne
acte est une activité de marché
c'est-à-dire pas une pas uniquement si
elles ont un lieu d'établissement dans
ces pays donc oui c'est une seule une
vraie révolution et ça m'a vraiment dans
le bon sens isabelle this saint-jean
c'est la fin des paradis fiscaux alors
en tous les cas c'est un coin c'est un
coin et il faut absolument appuyé je
vais revenir sur l'évaluation de
l'impact
alors évidemment tout y est les travaux
qui ont été faits en particulier ceux de
l'observatoire européen de la fiscalité
qui vient de sortir une note très
précise avec un certain nombre de
scénarios et dans le cas d'un accord
international il regarde les taux de 2
15 21 et 25 % est effectivement et on
voit que dans tous les cas ces
bénéficiaires pour la france alors
évidemment c'est pas à la même hauteur
celle que si vous prenez 25% ses 26
milliard en plus pour les caisses de
l'état
et si en revanche vous arrivez à 15% on
naît entre eux alors eux ils estiment 1
quand une note du cae estimait que c'est
aux alentours de 8 milliards donc dans
tous les cas ces bénéficiaires et dans
tous les cas quoiqu'il en soit de toute
façon il est normal que
les entreprises multinationales
fusse-t-elle française un pay des impies
et participe de l'effort de la fiscalité
pour notre pays
surtout quand on sait que c'est quand
même les grandes gagnantes ans il ya
deux grands gagnants du phénomène de
mondialisation et la crise thunders et
les très grandes fortunes et les
multinationales
je pense que c'est immonde remettre de
la fiscalité sur ces sur ces axes sur ce
point sur le principe même de simples de
cette embauche j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde est d'accord mais
j'aimerais savoir si c'est oui ou non la
fin des paradis fiscaux
je pense qu'il faut d'abord il faut le
souhaiter mais je redis parce que quand
vous dites paradis fiscal paradis fiscal
et paradis fiscal c'est ça ce communisme
non avec des taux un peu différent
évidemment les relances je pense que on
ne peut pas accepter dans les heures que
connaît la planète de 2 de continuer à
voir des paradis fiscaux je crois que
c'est un objectif si si on partage pas
ses objectifs
je dirais que je pense quand même que on
est pour le moins décalés par rapport au
sens qui est qu'on doit donner à
l'engagement et notamment l'engagement
public mais également aux
responsabilités qu'on exerce
je crois que c'est une évidence après
moi je veux redire une chose laon il va
falloir jouer à découvert et va falloir
reconstruire des dispositifs à une
échelle à la fois nationale et
internationale des outils de fiscalité
et ça va également toucher par exemple
si on regarde la france ça va un autre
moment nous interpeller dire qu'on va
avoir aussi le sentiment d'être un peu d
me de marge de manoeuvre du fait de
l'arrivée d'une taxe
mondiale qui participe je pense d'un
besoin et d'un équilibre nouveau
nécessaire a bâti que voulait dire c'est
qu'il va falloir coopérer à l'échelle
internationale de manière beaucoup plus
intense qu'avant
ben oui et puis de commencer par l'union
européenne il faut donc enfin l'union
européenne reconnaisse qu'il existe en
son sein des paradis fiscaux
on a cité l'irlande dans la cité les
pays bas le luxembourg je rappelle les
révélations fracassantes du mois de
février la open luxe le journal le monde
a fait une enquête là-dessus 55000
sociétés offshore 6500 milliards
d'actifs détenus par ces sociétés
offshore donc au sein d'une europe et y
est les paradis fiscaux cantoria la
liste officielle des paradis fiscaux
tels que conçus par l'union européenne
ne figure aucun de ces états je peux
citer d'autres exemples des bermudes
microsoft a son siège à dublin en
irlande l'irlande c'est union européenne
a fait 3 125 milliards de dollars de
profits l'an dernier en payant 0 dollars
d'impôts géré employés parce que le
siège officiel de la filiale et
microsoft se trouve aux bermudes où la
l'impôt société est à 0% alors si on
veut un impôt c'était à 0%
il faut le décider mais il faut changer
la société alors on parle beaucoup
d'europe depuis tout à l'heure et la
chine on n'en parle presque pas la chine
il faut pourtant en parle et agnès
verdier molinié
on dit quoi aux chinois pour les
convaincre avec cette difficile question
de hong kong notamment avec une
fiscalité pour le moins avantageuses
pour les chinois pour essayer de les
convaincre
ça va être effectivement compliqué
évidemment c'est que le début de la
négociation à moi j'ai envie aussi qu'on
parle pas simplement d' impôt minimum et
d'impôt maximum parce que je trouve que
ce serait incohérent se dire que peut
être qu'il ya un plancher mais qu'il ya
aussi un plafond nos entreprises
françaises sont les plus imposées par
rapport à tous les pays comparables
il n'y a pas qu'au l'impôt sur les
sociétés il faut bien se dire qu'il ya
aussi toute la caisse
deux taxes sur la production qui pèse
sur nos entreprises c'est 99 milliards
en 2019 donc voyez l'impôt sur les
sociétés c'est une trentaine de
milliards
les taxes sur la production c'est 99
milliards c'est plus de 400 milliards
qui sont payés par nos entreprises en
prélèvements obligatoires au total
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est toujours sur
les questions de minimum alors que nous
ce qu'ils nous fixent qui handicape
notre pays c'est aussi le fait qu'on
soit allé beaucoup plus loin que les
autres pays au niveau de taxation si on
se mettait rien qu'au niveau de la zone
euro on serait à 6 points de pib de
moins 150 milliards de moins donc moi
j'aimerais qu'on regarde les sujets sous
tous les angles
oui à mettre d impôt minimum mais il
faut aussi mettre finalement du maximum
dans cette danse est question parce que
notre compétitivité notre industrie on
parle de l'industrialiser la france on
parle de développer des entreprises en
france qui nous parle de créer des
emplois marchands en france est
absolument essentiel je crois que c'est
un des axes de campagne qui va se se
décider pour 2022
il faut absolument on est un vrai débat
sur ce sujet et qu on occulte pas sa
part des gros débat sur le taux d'impôt
sur les sociétés qui finalement est une
toute petite partie de l'impôt payé par
nos entreprises il faut bien se mettre
ça dans la tête
merci beaucoup isabelle this saint jean
vous êtes d'accord il faut aussi 1 1 ap
au maximum en quelque sorte
non c'est toujours la même logique bon
et si on regarde effectivement faut
avoir une perspective globale et
regardez l'intégralité de ce qui pèse
sur les entreprises mais il faut aussi
regarder à ce moment là les subventions
dont bénéficient les entreprises
françaises
voilà et donc c'est à ce moment là on
voit des chiffres complètement différent
qui apparaissent
j'en donne deux simplement en restant
sur l'impôt sur les sociétés si on
regarde
le poids de l'impôt sur les sociétés
dans le pipe en france alors
effectivement facialement on a un taux
beaucoup plus important mais sauf que on
a une base qui est tout ni té si vous
passez l'expression et le résultat c'est
qu'on est à 2 24% du pipe quand la
moyenne le cds et 3,14
si vous regardez un autre chiffre qui
est donné par le fmi
vous voyez que la productivité indices
de productivité l'impôt sur les sociétés
est aussi extrêmement faible donc c'est
une on a une série de tuyaux qui rendent
qui sortent donc moi je veux bien qu' au
regard de l'ensemble et à ce moment-là
regardons aussi ce qui entre en et puis
surtout arrêtons de penser que
l'attractivité d'un pays c'est
simplement lié à st
l'attractivité d'un pays comme la france
c'est aussi la qualité de ses services
publics c'est aussi là le niveau
d'éducation c'est plein de choses c'est
pas seulement s'en est donc là c'est
vraiment toujours la même logique qui
est logique qu'on sully et depuis
maintenant le début des années 80 et qui
nous amène dans la situation dans
laquelle on est aujourd'hui je crois que
là on est dans un moment de tourner en
gras c'est effectivement ce qui se passe
aux etats unis
mais j'aimerais le gouvernement soit
plus on est lui plus ambitieux lambeaux
bio de bon sens quand même un peu faible
sur il a vraiment appuyé les 21 faire
son pain d'occidentaux isabelle this
saint-jean
j'aimerais juste j'aimerais juste vous
entendre messieurs les sénateurs on sait
qu'on se dirige vers un alignement des
fiscalités en europe peut-être d'abord
ou pas du tout c'est un chantier qu'il
faut ouvrir d'urgence le chantier de
l'harmonisation du boulot du boulot en
mettant fin à la règle de l'unanimité
sur les questions fiscales hausse à
l'union européenne
messieurs ils sont bons je pense qu'il
faut effectivement de la coordination je
pense que c'est
et c'est vraiment ce qui doit permettre
à l'europe de grandir la coordination et
de l'identité aussi des pays membres
voilà il faut travailler sur les deux
c'est l'europe c'est finalement c'est un
tandem il faut pas que l'europe prenne
le pas de trop sur les pays et leurs
marges de manoeuvre et il faut par
contre que les nations est une ambition
européenne plus forte
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ces débats pour des raisons
d'équité je rappelle que jean françois
buisson vous êtes candidat aux
régionales et on va donc voir les autres
listes en course pour ces régionales
donc des 20 et 27 juin merci à vous
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ce débat
il est 14h30 les questions d'actualité
vont bientôt débuter tout le monde est
en place toute la brochette de
journalistes et en place quand un chalmé
et en salle des conférences gens m'a
scié et sur twitch vous le voyez jérôme
rabier est au coeur de la machine il est
dans l'hémicycle et jérôme vous avez
peut-être quelques éléments sur les
questions qui vont être posées
cet après midi au gouvernement oui steve
à une séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement qui s'ouvrira par une
déclaration solennelle de gérard larcher
au lendemain de l'agression des manuels
macron dans la drôme
le président du sénat qui a déjà dénoncé
un acte intolérable une atteinte à la
république et ses valeurs
il pourrait insister sur le climat plus
générale de la vie politique et évoqué
les nombreuses agressions notamment
d'élus locaux et de mer en particulier
mais aussi d'enseignants de policiers
gendarmes
à noter qu'en dehors de cette
intervention de gérard larcher
aucune question ne sera posée sur ce
thème comme si les sénateurs qui ont
tous dénoncé un cet acte ne voulait pas
non plus les données une nouvelle
résonance aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
en revanche on parlera comme chaque
semaine duco vide et de ses conséquences
avec plusieurs questions sur ce thème
où en est la campagne de vaccination
interrogera par exemple dany wattebled
pour le groupe les indépendants ou
encore une question sur
la compensation financière pour les
communes qui ont engagé des frais
pendant le coc vide au moment même où un
nouveau texte budgétaire est attendu au
parlement de nombreuses questions
également sur l'agenda social
rené paul savary le monsieur retraites
ici un du groupe l'est républicain
interrogera le gouvernement sur le
possible retour devant le parlement de
cette réforme explosive avant la
présidentielle de 2000 22
côté parti socialiste annie le houérou
posera une question sur l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage prévue au 1er juillet on sait
que la gauche veut un report ou même une
annulation de cette réforme voilà steve
pour les principaux thèmes abordés
cet après midi et on suivra ça et vous
dans maintenant trente minutes merci
beaucoup géraud allez on passe au second
thème de cette émission la fameuse pma
pour tout pour tout et bien ça veut dire
pma aussi pour les femmes seules et les
femmes lesbiennes et ça ça ne fait pas
l'unanimité la preuve sur ce plateau ou
j'accueille dominique de legge sénateur
lr d'ille-et-vilaine bonjour vous êtes
membre de la commission spéciale sur la
bioéthique et michel meunier sénatrice
socialiste de loire-atlantique et vice
présidente de la commission spéciale sur
la bioéthique bonjour merci d'être avec
nous la loi bioéthique et donc examinée
actuellement et pour la troisième fois à
l'assemblée nationale et cette fois 7
pourrait bien être la bonne regard des
sujets il est signé gaspard flamand
l'assemblée nationale vote de nouveau en
faveur de l'ouverture de la pma à toutes
les femmes
mesure phare du projet de loi bioéthique
et promesses de campagne d'emmanuel
macron le texte va maintenant revenir
une troisième fois devant le sénat le 15
juin en commission et le 24 juin en
séance publique
mais l'ouverture de la pma à tout
suscite beaucoup d'opposition tant qu'on
aura pas prouvé que pour un enfant
l'absence d'un père est sans conséquence
je préfère la prudence
il ya aussi une autre raison je ne vois
pas à partir du moment où on va accorder
aux femmes cette possibilité au nom de
quoi on pourrait refuser la même
possibilité par la gpa la gestation pour
autrui aux hommes
pourtant en 2019 la chambre haute avait
dit oui à la pma pour tout à condition
qu'elles ne soient pas remboursés par la
sécurité sociale mais il y aquelques au
mans en deuxième lecture
tournement de situation l'article en est
finalement retirée du texte dans sa
globalité
une issue qui avait déploré le président
du sénat je regrette un peu que le sénat
ait laissé passer la chance d'améliorer
le texte je le dis comme je le ressens
vous connaissez ma position c'est dit
que le texte de 2019 était pour moi un
texte équilibré et je ne suis pas
certain que l'équilibré trouvé en 2019
et d'ailleurs dans un dialogue à
l'accord avec la ministre de la santé
soient retrouvés c'est donc dans ce
contexte avec une gauche favorable au
projet de loi est une droite divisée sur
la question que le sénat va entamer
cette troisième et dernière lecture
avant une adoption définitive prévue
pour le mois de juillet dominique de
legge ce texte s'il revient au sénat
dans deux semaines vous évoquez la
galère vous dites quoi pas de compromis
sur la pma pour toutes du passage on dit
simplement que faut que le président de
la république tienne parole au huitième
round c'était la mer
rappelez vous il nous a dit il faut
qu'on aille vers un consensus
et puis qu'est-ce que je découvre encore
hier monsieur véran qui nous dit de
toute façon les décrets d'application
sont prêts et les premiers enfants à
naître de la pma naîtront il avait dit
au sein pendant une nuit enfin je veux
dire c'est quand même intéressant de
nous dire
débattez on cherche consensus mais toute
façon les décrets sont déjà ficelés et
madame la présidente de la commission
des lois
hier à l'assemblée a déclaré de toute
façon nous voterons le texte que
gouvernement nous a proposé et c'est ce
que sont en train de faire les députés
de ceux de rétablir le texte à la
virgule près initial du gouvernement si
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle le dialogue et
le consensus je pense qu'on ne met pas
le même sens où les mêmes mots avant de
vous donner la parole michel mais
j'aimerais juste comprendre quelque
chose parce que la pma pour toutes elle
avait été votée au sénat en première
lecture elle n'avait pas été en deuxième
lecture
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre temps et
qui ce qui va se passer dans deux
semaines vous savez très bien que sur
l'article l'a7 un problème d' incidents
de séance
où il ya un amendement était passé
c'était pas prévu qu'ils passaient un
autre qui ne vais pas passer
il s'est trouvé c'est prouvé ja repose
sénat paradoxalement et consensus pour
des articles ne satisfaisait personne
mais vous savez très bien que le sujet
il est pas là le sujet c'est celui de la
filiation
on y reviendra alors là je vraiment
paris lille il est là le sujet on peut
pas mentir aux enfants sur la pma pour
tout vous mais vous savez très bien que
sur la pma pour tout à l'intérieur du
rove auquel j'appartiens
les avis sont relativement partagés
alors michel mail et vous vous êtes
clairement pour la pma pour tout ça
pourrait donc être la grande réforme
sociétale d'emmanuel macron c'est une
réforme que vous aurez pu dû peut-être
vous la gauche adopté déjà peut-être
sous françois hollande
oui tout à fait mais je l' ai déjà dit
et même ici je pense que c'est un
rendez-vous qu'on a ratés lors du
précédent quinquennat et donc pour ma
part donc je suis favorable à
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
pour les femmes et les couples de femmes
et je pense que la promesse du candidat
macron à l'époque et aujourd'hui
président va se réaliser mais que de
temps que de temps il aura fallu et avec
des débats ont certes qui ont pu être
constructif pour la plupart mais
quelquefois qui a dû retarder des
mesures en tout cas une réalité qui j'ai
du mal à penser qu'elle puisse se mettre
en oeuvre avant 2000
23 vous croyez au gouvernement quand il
dit qu'on pourra finalement faire ses
premiers parcours de pma avant la fin de
l'année j'ai du mal parce que vont vous
le savez une gestation c'est quand même
neuf mois il va y avoir des mesures qui
sont qui vont changer a notamment sur
l'accès aux origines en tout cas la
levée de l'anonymat des donneurs qui va
peut-être en tout cas qui va modifier le
paysage de toute façon des donneurs je
dis pas qu'ils valent à supprimer parce
que
il aura toujours donc des don altruiste
qui existeront et c'est tant mieux
puisque on maintient la gratuité des
dons en france et là dessus il ne faut
pas tergiverser donc mais ça prendra du
temps et il nécessairement peut y avoir
un décalage au détriment des projets
parentaux des familles qui porte ce
projet dominique delage est ce que on
aurait évité les incidents dont vous
parliez un peu plus tôt si on avait fait
finalement une loi sur la bioéthique et
une loi sur la pma pour toutes
c'est une chose sur laquelle nous sommes
tous d'accord commencé par votre
collègue monsieur je m'y étais
rapporteur qu'il est nous avons tous dit
la même chose
c'est une erreur d'avoir voulu dans le
cadre d'une loi de bioéthique traité
d'un problème de société
donc je suis intimement convaincu que le
débat aurait été beaucoup plus clair et
que vous êtes vous aurions pu aller vers
un consensus
si effectivement on avait fait la
distinction entre ce qui relève de
l'éthique proprement dite avec toutes
ses implications en matière de recherche
et ce qui relève d'un débat de société
ce sont deux choses différentes
et là encore il ya une confusion est-ce
qu'elle était volontaire ou involontaire
je n'en sais rien mais ce qui me semble
aujourd'hui c'est que la priorité des
priorités est la lande attentes des
français c'est sans doute tout de même
pas la paix mais je crois que d'autres
ça j'ai donc j'ai fui il ya beaucoup de
femmes les femmes demandent bien évident
exige ne le nie pas et qu'ils attendent
depuis déjà deux trois ans de bd mais
qu'est ce que c'est que beaucoup et
qu'est ce que c'est aujourd'hui que la
priorité pour le gouvernement et pour
notre pays je pense que la situation
sanitaire la situation économique
méritent peut-être aussi que la priorité
du gouvernement soit ailleurs et qu'on
soit capable de se rassembler sur des
sujets consensuels face à la crise que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui un coup
vous parliez de consensus est sûre il y
aurait pu y avoir aussi un consensus sur
cette thema pour tout vous pensez
si c'était si on l'avait examiné un
texte séparé je pense que si on avait
examiné le texte d'autres de façon
séparée
nous n'aurions pas pu cette confusion
des genres laquelle nous avons assisté
qui n'a fait que rendre le débat confus
votre groupe à inscrire dans le texte en
deuxième lecture de la formule suivante
il n'existe pas de droit à l'enfant
vous considérez qu'il existe ce droit
aujourd'hui michel magne et alors ça
c'est entendu et réentendu parce que
rabâcher le droit à l'enfant pour moi
n'existe pas il y a un projet parental
qui existent et qui fonde tout un conte
soir un homme une femme un couple
hétérosexuel un couple homosexuel il y a
au départ est à l'origine un projet
parental on veut faire famille mais le
droit à l'enfant n'existe pas et il est
souvent brandie pour être un un contre
arguments à ceux qui sont pour la
liberté et le droit de choisir ses
maternités et de choisir la façon de
procréer qu'est ce que vous répondez à
sa nuque de lège aussi d'autant plus à
l'aise que c'est moi qui ai déposé cet
ajustement est qu'il a écrit vais pas
les citer mais je sais en mai quand tout
à l'heure je parlais de consensus il me
semble que le gouvernement aurait pu
donner un avis de sagesse et l'assemblée
nationale garder cet amendement je sais
si limites sur le plan juridique pour
autant c'était un signal qui était
envoyé
et peut-être que serait permis d'aller
vers le consensus mais en récusant même
cet amendement sur lequel tout le monde
au fond était d'accord je pense que le
gouvernement a perdu une occasion a
perdu une occasion de montrer que
effectivement il cherchait à rassembler
plutôt qu'à diviser et c'était dans ce
sens là que j'ai déposé cet amendement
c'était justement pour au moins dès le
départ au début de la loi montré qu'ils
avaient un point sur lequel nous étions
tous d'accord
une ligne que personne ne voulait
franchir quel dommage est ce que le
gouvernement n'ait pas saisi la main
donc vous reconnaissez aujourd'hui que
la bataille est perdue sur la pma pour
tout mais
c'est pas dans ces termes que ça se pose
parce qu'il reste une lecture donc il va
y avoir cette année ses auteurs la versa
en cause demain
vraisemblablement les pma passera eli
roth des enfants qui naîtront avec une
procréation médicalement assistée
le vrai sujet que poser maintenant c'est
la question du code civil et de la
filiation faire croire à des enfants qui
sont nés de deux mères c'est quand même
les tromper vous en conviendrez et
réformer notre code civil réforme est en
quelque sorte notre pôle vie de notre
société
uniquement pour satisfaire cette demande
je trouve ça dommage et donc il eût été
souhaitable que à l'assemblée nationale
au mois sur cet article quatre sur la
filiation que nous avons réécrit
justement pour permettre l'accès à la
paix m'a quand même un con mais il est
fort dommage que à l'assemblée nationale
on se soit pas saisie de cette porte que
nous avons ouvert il est donc deuxième
exemple du refus du consensus et du
dialogue
il ya un texte c'est celui du
gouvernement il passera coûte que coûte
et circulez ya rien à voir
michel meunier prochaine étape la gpa
non bien sûr que non
et c'est là où le désaccord entre cas
avec monsieur de lège
il ya un point commun ce qui aura une
grande frustration des parlementaires du
sénat quand nous aurons ce texte puisque
les les jeux sont faits et gestes sans
jeu de mots mais on voit bien que cette
troisième lecture va ressembler
fortement à la première voilà mais là où
je suis pas d'accord c'est sur les
questions de filiation parce que quand
j'ai dit tout à l'heure faire famille je
pense aussi à toutes ces familles par
adoption qui elle depuis bien longtemps
et en plus avec des profils de
célibataires puisque à célibataire peu
adoptée en france font famille et il n'y
a pas de filiation biologique
évidemment qui questionne cette famille
là et ce sont les familles comme les
autres donc pour revenir à votre
question non parce que le don doit être
anonyme et gratuit et il n'y a pas de
marchandisation du corps il ne devra pas
y en avoir il n'y en a pas les européens
de gpa et donc il n'y aura pas de gp apr
puisque c'est ça la ne le souhaitait pas
je ne souhaite pas personnellement non
vous êtes d'accord avec 2002 l'aise
quand il dit que c'est un changement
anthropologique un changement de société
dans laquelle on se dirige c'est une
évolution un changement oui mais quand
on regarde ce que changement ça voudrait
dire qu'on regrette où on tourne la page
de ce qui a existé non je pense que les
familles qui sont dans leur parcours
elles auront aussi la place à faire pour
des familles qui n'ont pas eu le même
parcours qui n'ont pas eu la même
histoire
dominique de legge j'aimerais tant que
madame meunier raison en disant qu'il y
aura pas de gp
on nous avait vendu le mariage pour tous
en nous disant jamais irak pma et je
vois pas comment demain au nom de
l'égalité hommes-femmes
on va pouvoir refuser à des hommes ce
que l'on accorde à des femmes donc zappé
mars et forcément la porte ouverte
demain à loger p1 ce sera le mot de la
fin de la fin de ce premier débat il est
14h45 à présent vous restez avec nous a
parlé d autres sujets d'actualité bien
évidemment j'aimerais vous faire réagir
parce que dans l'actualité également il
ya évidemment cette gifle cette gifle
administrée au chef de l'état c'était
hier lors d'un déplacement dans la drôme
on va retrouver tout de suite jean mas
siégeant maciel à gifles j'imagine que
ça fait beaucoup réagir t internautes
absolument steve tu t'en doutes beaucoup
d'internautes l'ont vu cette gifle
hier elle fait beaucoup réagir elle fait
débattre certains internautes trouvent
qu'on en parle trop et d'autres
internautes trouvent qu'au contraire
elle et elle est symptomatique sedif
d'une montée des tensions une montée des
tensions de montée des violences que
l'on constate dans le débat public
ça fait ça fait référence notamment à
des travaux qui avaient été menées
sénateurs sur les agressions contre les
maires ces élus locaux un récemment
encore été passée à tabac il y à il ya
quelques jours seulement
la gifle reçue par le chef de l'état
elle aussi symptomatique du coût de
cette montée des violences à compter de
violence en politique que l'on a
retrouvé aussi il ya quelques jours dans
cette vidéo de youtube heures d'extrême
droite papa sitôt qui met en scène la
fusillade tout simplement d'un électeur
d'un électeur de gauche ça aussi ça a
énormément fait réagir les internautes
qui se pose beaucoup de questions sur
les discours d'extrême droite est ce que
l'extrême droite n'est pas en train de
tenter de déplacer encore le curseur un
peu plus loin donc beaucoup de réactions
tu t'en doutes et une attente cet
après-midi de la parole notamment de
gérard larcher le président du sénat on
attend de voir
et si lui aussi va condamner aussi
fermement que tout le reste de la classe
politique ce geste
gérard larcher qui devrait effectivement
dire quelques mots en ouverture de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup aux gens on te retrouve
tout à l'heure peut-être une réaction
une agression physique contre un chef de
l'état c'est une agression contre notre
république michel meunier tout à fait
c'est inadmissible et rien ni personne
ne peut l'expliquer le cautionner ou le
justifier on va tout de suite retrouvé
quentin qu'elle mais qui est en salle
des conférences quentin vous êtes avec
eliane assassi la présidente du groupe
communiste est tout à fait steve
effectivement alors selon les
informations du parisien madame cécile
sommes retenus en garde à vue n'explique
pas vraiment son geste d'hier pas plus
qu'il n'est mais une quelconque
revendication précise une source proche
du dossier évoque une espèce de bouillie
idéologique alors de quoi cette gifle et
elle le symptôme selon vous écoutez
d'abord je pense qu'il faut condamner
cet acte c'est inacceptable qu'une
personne quelle qu'elle soit puisse
gifler le président de la république
comme il est inacceptable de toute façon
qu'il y ait des violences dans d'autres
sociétés que cette personne aide à
bouilly dans la tête je veux bien
concevoir cela dit
il a tenu des propos quand même qu'ils
sont assez révélateurs d'une orientation
politique me semble t'il donc je ne sais
pas ce qu'il va advenir de sacs à la à
l'issue de sa garde à vue
mais visiblement ce personnage et quand
même issu d'une mouvance d'extrême
droite donc qui relevait par tout le
monde
donc on verra ce que donnera la suite de
l' enquête mais pour l'instant on en est
là gérard larcher doit prendre la parole
en ouverture de cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement au
nom du sénat tout entier il doit
dénoncer a unanimement ces faits c'était
important c'est important que la
représentation nationale
aujourd'hui face unanimité sur le sujet
oui bien sûr ça c'est très important
d'ailleurs dès hier je crois que tous
les présidents de groupe ici au sénat
mais je crois que c'était le cas aussi à
l'assemblée nationale ont dénoncé ce qui
s'est passé à tain l'hermitage je trouve
que c'est bien effectivement que
unanimement la représentation nationale
et la haute chambre puisse effectivement
dire sa colère face à de tels
agissements
ce qui déjà sur twitter a dénoncé et
bien une violence qui se développe dans
notre on l'a tous dénoncé ainsi moi vous
savez j'ai adressé j'ai envoyé un tweet
hier dans lequel jeudi outre le fait que
c'est inacceptable de ce qui s'est passé
je dis qu'il faut redonner du sens et
des contenus au débat d'idées à la
démocratie je crois que l'on souffre
aujourd'hui dans ce pays de ce manque de
deux confrontations d'idées de
confrontation par le verbe
c'est très important tous les élus sont
vraiment ont la bonne attitude quand on
voit des manifestations dans la réforme
des retraites des parlementaires qui
vont comme ça singer
nate où il frappe un même quartier j'ai
repris ce ne sont pas tous les élus je
suis président du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique et je
peux vous assurer que les événements
groupe n'ont jamais eu de tels
agissements dans une magnifique dans une
manifestation de quelque nature qu'elles
soient
et dieu sait qu des fois c'est difficile
c'est très difficile mais nous n'avons
jamais commis des actes de d'une nature
violente sur qui que ce soit d'ailleurs
mais je ne parlerai que non visibles
bien sûr est que pouvez-vous faire en
plus pour apaiser encore davantage je
crois qu'il faut se rapprocher des
citoyens c'est ce que je me disais c'est
à dix elle redonner un petit peu du sens
il y a des idées à défendre et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne défend plus des
idées on le confronte plus des idées et
ça laisse effectivement la place à des
invectives à des violences
et ça on ne peut pas l'accepter moi je
vois dans les campagnes électorales de
ce2 cm2 se détendit qui sont présents la
question principale c'est d'avoir des
débats avec des gens si ça qui compte
merci beaucoup on appelle on entend cet
appel au débat avec des mots
effectivement eliane assassi à ce micro
aujourd'hui merci merci beaucoup
quentin inacceptable pour eliane assassi
on viens de l'entendre
la présidente du groupe communiste qui
condamne évidemment cette agression du
chef de l'état dominique de legge d
agression contre un homme politique
contre un chef de l'état on les a on en
a déjà vu plusieurs fois par le passé
pourtant on est toujours saisie du même
choc
pourquoi comment vous l'expliquez je
sais pas l'expliquer souffre peut-être
pas une certaine forme de banalisation
de la violence de la violence mais aussi
quelquefois de la fonction voilà je
pense qu'il faut si sa fonction de
président de la république vous voulez a
quand même quelques images par moments
qui peuvent prêter à choquer et y
compris de dans les médias et de la part
des médias
ce que vous voyez on voyait tout à
l'heure le président sarkozy sa
marionnette battue ça passe en boucle ça
finit par s'appliquer une responsabilité
des médias selon vous dans cette fosse
il y des dvd en tant que tel je dis
quelle responsabilité collective
à un moment donné ces images elles
véhiculent un message et ce message il
finit par percolé lui suffit pas de
dénoncer moi je suis sur la même
longueur d'onde que ma collègue monnier
et nous dénoncerons tous avec le
président larcher qui est arrivé est
inadmissible
ça doit être condamné alors que
simplement il faut aussi se poser un
certain nombre de questions et pas
simplement dire c'est pas bien treize
petites précisions on a choisi ici sur
public sénat de ne diffuser l'image de
cette agression des manuels mâcon qu'une
seule fois contrairement donc à d'autres
d'autres chaînes de télévision on va
tout de suite retrouvé quand un calme
inquiétant salle des conférences quentin
vous êtes avec roger karoutchi
exactement vice-président à l'ère du
sénat bonjour monsieur karoutchi et on
attend un message en début de cette
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement de gérard larcher au nom du
sénat c'était important d'avoir une
unanimité de tous les groupes politiques
pour dénoncer le geste qui s'est passé
hier dans la drôme
oui oui ça ne changera pas la face du
monde ni la vie publique française
mais c'est important de dire que ça
suffit qu est que la violence érigé un
système par certains parce qu'il n'ya
pas assez de sanctions parce qu'un passé
d'unités et que cette violence n'est pas
admis si pas plus d'ailleurs à l'égard
du président la république à l'égard de
l'ensemble des élus qu'à l'égard des
policiers des gendarmes des médecins des
enseignants faut que ça s'arrête le
climat de violence dans ce pays doit
s'arrêter voilà ne changera pas le monde
ce qui va nous rester en séance
aujourd'hui que peut-on faire
collectivement où vous les élus les
aussi le législateur est ce qu'il ya des
solutions à cette violence pourquoi
toujours les élus vous aussi les médias
tu es responsable c'est on va pas faire
une loi supplémentaire
il ya suffisamment de textes de lois
pour réprimer la violence pour réprimer
la délinquance pour épauler ce que vous
voulez mais il faut que collectivement
médias élus syndicats tout le monde que
tout le monde fasse un peu de pédagogie
pour dire dans ce pays est en démocratie
et en république
le débat il hisse dans les idées
le débat qui se tranchent par les urnes
par le vote pas par la violence pas par
une violence qui est devenu érigés en
système
oh ya plus une seule manifestation dans
ce pays où il n'y a pas d'actes de
violence c'est n'y a plus une seule
réunion ne craignent pas la violence
donc il faut que ça s'arrête et il faut
que chacun reprenne ses esprits et
reviennent à la raison
j'ai arraché après d'une violence qui se
développe dans notre mais dans notre
pays qui a été le point de bascule selon
vous est ce qu'il ya eu ce moment de
bascule dans la violence politique
je pense que la bascule elle est en
plusieurs étapes d'abord avec par
définition les actes terroristes qui ont
mis la violence à l'extrême dans des
conditions aberrante pour notre pays
mais enfin qui a existé et puis ensuite
le fait que par exemple les black blocks
ou chers certes un gilet jaune ont
pratiqué la violence dans les
manifestations
alors je reconnais que celle et gilet
jaune c'était plutôt les black blocks
qui alléchés gilet jaune pour faire de
la violence mais on n'a pas réussi à
maîtriser ce phénomène des black blocks
on n'a pas réussi à fait à maîtriser le
phénomène de la violence maintenant on
est tous confrontés au fait que la
violence est devenue un système de vis
pour certains voilà avant de vous
libérer je ne peux pas ne pas vous poser
la question ce matin les salaires ont
présenté un système de départage sur la
primaire à droite
qu'est ce que vous en pensez eh bien
vous le saurez le 28 après les élections
locales puisque je les dis je ne
m'exprime pas là dessus avant les
élections départementales et régionales
on gagne d'abord les élections
départementales et régionales on règle
nos affaires après merci beaucoup merci
karoutchi merci quand on vous avez vous
avez donc essayé de poser cette question
sur sur les primaires chez les élèves ça
suffit nous dit roger karoutchi
il faut que ça s'arrête roger karoutchi
qui en appelle à la responsabilité
collective en quelques mois michel magne
est ce qu un climat délétère est en
train de s'installer en france
je ne crois pas par contre il ya une
forte visibilité de ces exactions et
c'est regrettable et c'est du à
on va aura je pense qu'il faut que je
reste et je resterai sur cette
expression de responsabilité collective
mais chacun et chacune nous avons notre
part on va retrouver quand un calme et
une nouvelle fois qui est avec quentin
vous êtes avec hervé
marseille le président du groupe
centriste exactement le président du
groupe centriste au sénat
bonjour monsieur mars alain larcher qui
va introduire cette séance des questions
écrites au gouvernement avec cette
phrase cette agression est un symptôme
symbolique qui illustre la montée de la
violence dans notre société
c'était important qu'ils aient ce
message aujourd'hui en ouverture et en
ouverture de la séance absolument je
crois qu'il y a des limites au débat et
la violence est une limite on ne peut
pas accepter la violence encore moins
sur le chef de l'état qui nous
représente tous on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec le chef de l'état mais il
ya d'autres moyens de le contester il ya
d'autres moyens de débattre et ce sont
ces moyens là qu'il faut utiliser on ne
peut pas accepter la violence en
politique
comment est-ce que vous analysez les
faits d'hier en garde à vue apparemment
les proches du dossier parle d'une
bouillie idéologique dans les brumes de
la personne qui a frappé le chef de
l'état qu'est ce que vous qu'est ce que
vous retenez vous de cet incident moi ce
que je retiens simplement c'est que dieu
merci pour l'instant ça reste quelque
chose comme l'a dit le chef de l'état d'
isoler je pense que faut pas
s'appesantir sur la personnalité de tel
ou tel illuminés qui s'en prend au chef
de l'état comme d'autres s'en sont pris
à des premiers ministres ou à d'autres
élus ça n'a pas de sens de dire que
peut-être il a une proximité avec la
droite de la droite qu'il a pu scander
un slogan royalistes ça n'a pas
d'intérêt non on va par veut parce qu'on
va pas chercher du complotisme derrière
tout ça je veux dire c c ou c'est un
acte isolé ou salés pas si c'est une
organisation à lenquête le démontrera et
on verra quelles conséquences en tirer
pour l'instant je veux croire que c'est
un acte isolé de quelqu'un qui qui est
un peu perturbé en revanche cette claque
elle doit nous réveiller le doigt elle
doit montrer qu' il faut organiser mieux
le débat public
on sent bien que notre société sous
pression après un an et demi de qu'ovide
de confinement on voit bien les
difficultés qui existent ici ou là sur
le plan psychologique beaucoup de gens
sont perturbées et puis il faut ré
ouvrir aérer le débat il faut que le
parlement reprenne toute sa place
on ne peut pas avoir une démocratie qui
se limite à 1
et cutif extrêmement puissant qui décide
de tout et l'opinion qui est condamné à
réagir positivement ou négativement
chacun se souvient d'épisodes douloureux
comme les gilet jaune comme les
manifestations qui a pu y avoir sur les
retraites sur la sur les grèves qui a pu
y avoir sur toutes sortes de sujets il
faut ré ouvrir le débat il faut le
réinstaller et le lieu si le parlement
oui et c'est ce que dont vous dites
qu'en fait l'exécutif a déjà peut-être
la solution à cette violence politique
c'est de mieux considérer toutes les
professions intermédiaires toutes les
personnes qui peuvent réinstaurer un
débat entre les populations en france
c'est ça que vous dites oui c'est ça que
je dis et je dis qu'on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça on peut pas continuer
à avoir d'un côté un exécutif qui décide
de tout qui est l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique en france
et puis de l'autre côté l'opinion qui
est condamné à réagir aux décisions qui
sont prises et à un lieu qui s'appelle
le parlement
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est le lieu du
débat c'est un instrument qui est le
symbole de la démocratie et c'est là que
se doit ce doivent se faire les grands
débats est ce que vous avez pu envoyer
un message à mgr lacroix aurait pu
communiquer avec le chef d'état d'une
façon ou d'une autre
et puis j'ai manifesté comme beaucoup
d'autres mon soutien dans cette affaire
et lui dire combien nous soutenons que
nous le soutenions mais je crois que
aujourd'hui il faut passer à autre chose
eh bien merci mais ils seraient minces
hay président du groupe centriste alors
que gérard lâcher quitte le bureau
départ pour rejoindre l'hémicycle on va
retrouver jérôme rade et en tribune de
presse de l'hémicyle jérôme dites-nous
tout sur le programme aujourd'hui elle
va gérard larcher un qui va s'installer
dans quelques secondes au plateau et qui
a décidé de prendre la parole il a tenu
à faire une déclaration solennelle au
lendemain de la gifle reçue par emmanuel
macron en déplacement dans la drôme
c'est un moment évidemment qui sera
attendu ensuite pour le traditionnel
rendez vous de vos mercredi après midi
seize questions au programme avec
notamment une question sur le retour au
parlement de la réforme des retraites
elle sera posée par rené paul savary le
monsieur retraites du groupe l'est
républicain autres réformes politiques
au programme de ces questions
d'actualité celle de l'assurance chômage
et c'est annie le houérou 1 pour le
groupe socialiste qui posera cette
question troisième réforme réforme des
retraites réforme de l'assurance-chômage
réforme de la justice est également
programmée c'est tout de suite puisque
la cloche a retenti telle issue vue nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y en a
t'il en séance
je n'en vois point le procès-verbal donc
adopté sous les réserves d'usagé
messieurs le premier ministre mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues au nom du sénat je souhaite
faire part de notre soutien et de notre
solidarité au président de la république
qui a été agressé hier dans la drôme
par cet acte inacceptable
c'est notre démocratie et la république
elle-même qui ont été attaqués cette
agression est un symptôme symbolique
un acte qui illustre une fois de plus la
montée de la violence dans notre société
certains discours et prises de position
sont de plus en plus marqués par
l'agressivité l'intolérance le refus du
débat démocratique
et aujourd'hui le complotisme ce sont
désormais les représentants de
l'autorité publique et du service public
qui sont victimes de ces violences
les élus et policiers et gendarmes des
pompiers
les soignants les enseignants et hier le
président de la république devant la
multiplication de ces actes
il est me semble-t-il de notre
responsabilité à nous
la nation mais aussi de la
responsabilité de l'ensemble des
citoyens de ce pays de faire vivre le
débat d'idées sans jamais transiger sur
le nécessaire respect dû aux personnes
et à la diversité des idées nous devons
veiller à faire vivre la démocratie dans
un cadre digne et apaisée tel est le
message que je souhaitais vous adresser
mes chers collègues ainsi qu'à tous ceux
qui nous regardent
à cet instant à l'ouverture de notre
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement la séance
est retransmise en direct sur public
sénat et notre site internet au nom du
bureau du sénat j'appelle chacun d'entre
vous mes chers collègues a observé au
cours de nos échanges
ce qui fait aussi nos valeurs
essentielles le respect le respect les
uns et les autres et bien sûr le respect
du temps parole je vais donner la parole
si vous le voulez bien
un autre collègue annie le houérou pour
le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
chers collègues vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
l'insee estime que depuis le 1er
confinement 29 % des ménages auraient
leurs revenus mensuels en baisse entre
mars 2020 et mars 2021
l'observatoire des inégalités dans son
rapport 2021 conclu que la crise
sanitaire agit comme un accélérateur des
inégalités elle précipite dans la propre
dans la pauvreté des personnes qui en
étaient proches
votre gouvernement met en oeuvre sa
réforme de l'assurance chômage
dans un contexte où beaucoup de français
ont encore la tête sous l'eau
d'après l'étude d'impact menée par
l'unedic un million cent cinquante mille
personnes vont constater une baisse
moyenne de 17% de leur allocation dont
345 milles jeunes qui sont ceux qui
pâtiront de cette réforme
les personnes qui a été en des contrats
courts de l'intérim et des périodes
d'inactivité
non pas par choix mais par impossibilité
de trouver des emplois stables
elle frappera à nouveau les jeunes à qui
vous ne proposer que des dispositifs
précaire cette réforme va toucher les
régions où le taux de chômage est le
plus fort
près de dix mille personnes dans mon
département des côtes d'armor plus de
52000 personnes en bretagne et aussi
deux cent mille personnes en ile de
france dont 45 mille jeunes
vous vanter une réforme porteuse de
justice sociale grâce au bonus malus sur
les contrats courts vous oubliez de
préciser que ce dispositif n'entrera en
vigueur qu'à l'automne 2022 alors que
les effets dévastateurs de votre réforme
seront effectifs dès ce
mois de juillet monsieur le ministre ne
pensez-vous pas que nos concitoyens les
plus précaires ont déjà lourdement payé
cette crise quel est le but de cette
réforme
si ce n'est de faire des économies une
fois de plus sur le dos des plus
vulnérables
je vous le demande monsieur le ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
abroger ces deux réformes pour vous
répondre la parole est alors en plus
trash et fils secrétaire d'état en
charge des retraites et de la santé au
travail
monsieur le ministre avait la parole je
remercie monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice le où j'ai pris connaissance
de l'étude effectivement que vous avez
évoqué du parti socialiste les chiffres
qui ont été repris sont issus
effectivement du cadrage de l'unedic
mais au total l'utilisation qui en est
fait amène à mettre ces chiffres dans
une étude erronée et les maîtres de
façon terriblement anxiogène parce qu'on
puisqu'ils sont tronqués et je vais vous
dire pourquoi
d'abord vous avez évoqué la situation
disparaître au niveau des régions oui je
pense que vous découvrez pas et moi non
plus qui suis issu des hauts de france
qu' il y a plus de chômage dans nord et
dans le sud du pays que dans d'autres
régions
donc si c'est pour faire une carte qui
indique juste les différences de densité
de population et de chômeurs je pense
que cela a peu au final d'intérêt
maintenant sur le fond de cette réforme
aucun demandeur d'emploi actuel ne sera
pénalisé aucun d'entre eux n'aura des
droits qui baisse au 1er juillet
c'est la réalité même si cela peut être
vous faire réagir mais c'est quand même
la réalité
je le redis la réforme ne concernera que
ceux qui se retrouveront sans emploi
au-delà de cette date seuls ceux qui
gagnent plus et bien sûr c'était un des
objets de la réforme en étant au chômage
plutôt qu'en travaillant pourront
toucher une allocation plus basse
effectivement il n'a pas échappé que y
compris dans ce qui était portée par
muriel pénicaud auparavant et part à
isabelle board et moi même
il y avait une volonté m de l'équité de
ce dispositif est de ne plus permettre à
ceux qui sont au chômage de tous et plus
au chômage qu'on travaille en mais là
encore le nombre total de leurs droits
ne baissera pas ceux qui auront une
allocation plus basse la toucheront plus
longtemps vous a pas échappé que le
capital en termes d'allocation chômage
resté le même et que simplement il sera
réparti sur une plus longue durée
donc la réalité c'est que droit global
est le même pour finir je souhaite
rappeler que le marché du travail est en
très nette reprise
madame la sénatrice et que vous avez
évoqué justement le fait que cette
réforme avait été pensé à un autre
moment mais nous voyons bien que la
situation économique actuelle la
justifiait aussi je vous remercie
mais aussi la parole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue maryse
carrère pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président avant de poser ma question
j'aimerais une nouvelle fois exprimé au
nom du groupe rdse toute notre
solidarité notre soutien au président de
la république suite à l'agression dont
il a été victime hier en république on
règle ses désaccords par le débat ou
dans les urnes
jamais par la violence ou d'intimidation
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre en charge des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre si n'ai plus besoin
de revenir sur l'impact dramatique de
l'épidémie de kobe 19 sur notre économie
et s'il est important de reconnaître
l'implication des pouvoirs publics aux
côtés des entreprises
il reste encore des zones d'ombré dans
les dispositifs du gouvernement qui
conviendraient d'éclaircir le pfr 4
semble vouloir combler ces lacunes
avec près de 200 millions d'euros prévus
pour les collectivités
malgré cela il semblerait que les
collectivités ayant été dans
l'obligation d'abandonner le budget de
leur régime de leur épique par leur
budget principal soit exclus des
dispositifs de compensation et je fais
référence ici à l'article 10 alinéa 7 du
plfr 4 face à l'injustice ressentie en
eux répondent répond à ces communes que
si elles ont compensé ces pertes de
recettes c'est qu'elle avait les moyens
de le faire on évoque une compensation
seulement pour les communes qui aurait
le plus souffert aussi je rappelle que
nombre d'entre eux se sont vus obligés
d'abandonner ses budgets pour faire face
aux frais de fonctionnement au paiement
des salaires ainsi qu aux créances
tout cela avec la double peine que l'on
connaît des budgets lourdement une pâle
impacté et des capacités
d'autofinancement corps est
considérablement réduite pour l'avenir
dans mon département des hautes pyrénées
si je prends la commune d'argelès gazost
ville de 2009 180 habitants ce sont près
de 400000 euros en 2020 et et 150000
euros en 2021 que la commune a dû verser
sans la moindre compensation ce qui a
amputé de moitié sa capacité
d'autofinancement
au final c'est une véritable distorsion
de concurrence qui est créé entre ces
communes
supportant des établissements aux
stations de ski gérer un
et j ou épiques et celle qui à ce jour
ont pu rentrer dans des dispositifs
existants face à l'inquiétude des élus
locaux en question est simple monsieur
le ministre les épiques seront
inéligibles aux différentes aides
prévues dans le plfr les régies seront
elles compensent et de leurs pertes de
recettes tarifaires y compris si les
communes ont compensé les déficits en
scène les régit les épiques dont les
activités annexes ont été rendue
impossible par la fermeture des
remontées mécaniques seront être
éligible merci pour vos réponses
la parole est à olivier dussopt ministre
délégué en charge des comptes publics
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice quelques mots
d'abord pour dire que avec les
différents projets de loi de finances
rectificative que le parlement a bien
voulu adopter les collectivités ont été
accompagnés vous l'avez rappelé
notamment avec un mécanisme de garantie
de recettes minimales en matière fiscale
et domaniale pour l'année 2020 reconduit
pour la partie fiscale en 2021
nous accompagnons aussi les autorités
organisatrices de mobilité par des
systèmes de compensation et d' avance
remboursable et à la demande du premier
ministre
nous allons élargir la prise en charge
de certaines dépenses des autorités
organisatrices de mobilité pour assurer
une égalité de traitement selon la
nature de leur service et vous nous avez
interrogé
nombreux sont les parlementaires à
l'avoir fait c'est la question des
régimes
je vous confirme que la demande d
premier ministre jacqueline gourault et
moi même avons longuement échangé avec
les associations représentatives des
lieux et l'article 10 du projet de loi
de finances rectificatif que j'aurai
l'occasion de défendre devant
l'assemblée nationale ce vendredi est au
tout début du mois de juillet devant
vous permettra une prise en charge pour
les régies qui ont vu leur épargne brute
baisser sensiblement au cours de l'année
2020 cet article dit ça permette d'aider
les services publics industriels et
commerciaux soumis à concurrence mais
privé dette publique dans certains cas
il va permettre d'aider les services
publics administratifs qui ont vu leurs
recettes tarifaires descendre et baisser
fortement et nous allons veiller par un
amendement que le gouvernement va
déposer pour la science à l'assemblée
nationale parce que les régies qui ont
fait l'objet d'un abondement et pour
lesquels l'abondement de la commune de
l'intercommunalité s'est traduit par une
diminution très forte de l'épargné brute
de ces collectivités
sa compagne et se sont unis le régime
que nous allons accompagner pour un peu
plus de 120 millions d'euros et nous
allons consacrer 80 millions d'euros à
une dotation forfaitaire à la main des
préfets de région et des préfets de
département pour accompagner les
collectivités communes et
intercommunalités qui rencontrent des
difficultés que vous avez évoqué les
régies thermale les remontées mécaniques
les grottes touristiques seront
concernés c'est le cas à argelès c'est
le cas l'ex en sauveur il a vingt régie
dans votre département qui sont
accompagnés je souhaite je forme le voeu
qu'elle amendements que nous
présenterons permettent de compléter le
dispositif
merci la parole et à notre collègue
esther benbassa pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire merci monsieur le
président et le président madame la
ministre un char inez le 4 mai à
mérignac blessé par arme à feu puis
brûlée vive par son ex mari
stéphanie le 23 mai hayange mortellement
poignardée à cinq reprises par son
compagnon
mais ce gab le 24 mai ravages ont tué à
coups de marteau
odile le 27 mai à valenciennes
mortellement poignardée par son
ex-compagnon jennifer le 30 mai à meyrin
ville a battu avec un laser levé par son
ex compagnon aurélie le 31 mai à doué
battu à mort par son compagnon
douze condamnations à son actif et doris
le 3 juin à colmar des fellahs ce défilé
c'est du huitième étage de son immeuble
peuvent sans conjoint ivre à qui il
était interdit de la prochaine depuis un
jugement
cent quarante six femmes tuées par leur
compagnon ou ex conjoint en 2010 900 ans
en 2020 et 49 cette année jusqu'au 5
juin
il était prévisible que les violences
contre les femmes allaient augmenter en
raison des confinement et couvre-feu
successifs le numéro d'appel dédié à
39,19 a reçu plus de 164 1000 appels
soit plus de 70 % en un an
seuls 60% de ces appels ont pu être pris
en charge
vous aviez pu mieux doter cette
plateforme afin que ce flux d'appels
puissent mieux
être traité il est urgent de donner plus
de moyens effectifs permanents
supplémentaires à la justice de
sensibiliser la police pour agir plus
efficacement de loger les femmes
victimes de violences les relations samb
l'éducation à l'égalité
l'engagement contre le patriarcat mérite
toute notre attention toute votre
attention
les lois ne servent que si on les
applique nous en sommes loin
oui les femmes sont en danger lisez le
rapport du haut conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes par lui
aujourd'hui il est édifiant devront mot
juste continuer à compter les victimes
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
la ministre déléguée en charge de
qualité entre les femmes et les hommes
changer de la diversité l'égalité des
chances madame elisabeth moreno vous
avez la parole madame la ministre je
vous remercie monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice benbassa vous
évoquez dans votre question des faits
dramatiques qu'aucune femme au monde ne
devrait subir
il ya encore quelques années ces faits
seraient restés invisibles et
aujourd'hui il occupe tous les esprits
et c'est tant mieux parce que chaque
féminicide est un féminicide de trop
comme vous le savez le gouvernement et
la majorité sont mobilisés et déterminés
depuis plusieurs années maintenant à
enrayer ce fléau dans notre pays
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
est la grande cause du président de la
république et la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes en est un
pilier essentiel
quel gouvernement a mis en place le
grenelle des violences conjugales qui a
réuni quatre mille cinq cents personnes
pour parler de ce sujet quel
gouvernement a voté en quatre ans quatre
lois pour protéger ces femmes qu'elles
gouvernement a augmenté de 60 % le
nombre de places d'hébergement pour
accueillir ses victimes
ce gouvernement
monter le nombre d'ordonnancés de
protection et doubler le nombre de
téléphones grave danger
il a mis en place les centres de prise
en charge des auteurs des vides et des
auteurs de ces violences
il a aussi été le premier pays à
verbaliser les violences sexuelles de et
sexiste de rue quel gouvernement a
encore étendu les horaires du 39 19
à partir du mois de juin qui sera
accessible 7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures
sur 24
et encore ce gouvernement augmente et le
permettez moi terminer c'est le
gouvernement a augmenté le budget de ce
ministère de carême pour ça pour
éradiquer ce fléau
je sais combien le sénat est sensible à
ces questions je sais combien vous vous
battez pour protéger ces femmes dans
notre pays
je rencontre la présidente annie billon
demain matin je vous rencontre bientôt
madame la sénatrice pour en parler et le
premier ministre nous recevra ce soir
avec les autres ministres pour voir ce
que nous devons encore faire pour faire
en sorte que les femmes conclut ne se
laisse pousser meurtres ces assassinats
qui deviennent intolérables dans notre
pays
merci sa parole et à notre collègue dany
wattebled pour le groupe les
indépendants république des territoires
vous avez deux minutes monsieur le
président madame miss mes chers
collègues lançant notre groupe s'associe
condamnation des violences dont le chef
de l'état a été l'objet dans nos
territoires mais aussi dense rassemblée
de nombreuses et de la république ont
connu les agressions inadmissibles quand
les porter atteinte aux élus c'est toute
la république qui souffrent c'est encore
plus symbolique quand c'était lui le
président de la république
ensemble nous devons nous mobiliser
contre la montée de ce climat
préjudiciable à notre démocratie
ma question porte sur la vaccination les
racines cas de thrombose ont amené à une
brève suspension du vaccin astrazeneca
jusqu'à escient de reprise par
l'autorité européenne du médicament
ce climat délétère un considérant
freiner l'élan de ce vaccin avec une
véritable désaffection des français à
son égard
c'est regrettable car il s'agit pourtant
d'un vaccin efficace
ces effets secondaires sont très limités
comme a pu le démontrer l'utilisation
massive
quant à fait le royaume uni madame la
ministre quelles actions sont envisagées
pour relancer la vaccination avec des
doses de 20 d'astrazeneca
si toutes les deux en attente dont le
chiffre se comptent par millions ne
trouvait pas preneur
pouvez vous nous dire ce qu'il
adviendrait de ses stocks de vaccins je
veux aussi attirer votre attention sur
la vision des personnes identifiées
comme à risque moins de la moitié de ces
personnes classées à risque pour que
cause d'obésité ont reçu à ce jour une
dose de vaccin après un démarrage
difficile de la vaccination
nous constatons que la france est aussi
nos partenaires européens sont
maintenant parmi les plus avancés il
reste néanmoins nécessaire de résoudre
ces deux problématiques
madame ici la manie ce quelle mesure
envisagez vous de prendre à cet égard
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la ministre déléguée en
charge de l'autonomie madame brigitte
bourguignon que nous félicitons par
ailleurs voilà vous avez la parole merci
à monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur dany eva de blé votre question
me permets de rappeler un point
essentiel la vaccination est l'outil
principal pour nous permettre de
retrouver une vie normale et c'est le
seul moyen dont nous disposons à ce jour
pour nous prémunir du virus nous
défendre efficacement contre celui ci
est protégé nos proches
le vaccin est une chance après une année
particulièrement difficile où les
français ont répondu présent à toutes
les mesures qui s'imposaient à eux ils
en ont bien compris la portée
ces résultats sont là plus de 28
millions et demi de français ont reçu au
moins une injection et près de 15
millions ont désormais un schéma
vaccinal complet cette campagne
s'accélère avec plus de 600 4 650 milles
vaccination hier trois stratégies trois
impératifs la sécurité sanitaire et
l'efficience des vaccins la priorisation
des publics les plus fragiles et le
libre choix des français
nous avons toujours fait le choix de la
transparence les données qui permettait
de répondre aux craintes des français
ont été rendus publics et les protocoles
adaptés en fonction la vaccination avec
la stran eca a repris par la suite
et ceux qui en ont bénéficié
porte bien je me porte très bien c'est
la meilleure preuve que nous puissions
donner à nos concitoyens nous cherchons
toujours à faciliter le recours à ces
vaccins
je veux rappeler qu'ils sont désormais
davantage disponible en médecine de
ville plutôt qu'en centre de vaccination
afin que les médecins traitants aille
vers leurs patients éligibles nos
efforts en matière d'aller vers que nous
déployons par plusieurs moyens
permettent de toucher les français qui
doivent être vaccinés en priorité les
associations dédiées les organisations
de professionnels de santé les acteurs
locaux et en particulier les élus sont
pleinement mobilisées je tiens à les en
remercier
dans votre département du nord que je
connais bien les efforts payent plus de
52% des personnes présentant une obésité
ont reçu au moins une dose de vaccin la
campagne s'intensifie dans votre
territoire
comme partout en france notre
mobilisation est donc totale et nous
comptons sur l'engagement de tous
évidemment pour réussir à vacciner le
plus largement possible je vous remercie
merci monsieur wiley vous avez quelques
secondes
merci votre réponse globale à nice mais
je pense qu'il va nous rester pas mal de
doses d'astrazeneca y aurait peut-être
quelque chose à faire pour relancer ses
ce vaccin je remercie la parole à notre
collègue muriel jourda pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
ce président est cher collègue ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le garde
des sceaux qui est absent en mars 2019
mais mme belloubet faisait alors adopté
un texte pour un style et des réformes
structurelles dans la justice et
redonner confiance aux français dans
l'institution judiciaire
cela n'a guère été efficace semble-t-il
puisque moins de deux ans après le garde
des sceaux annonce est une nouvelle loi
qui voulait aussi redonner confiance
dans la justice aux français
ça doit n'ai pas encore discuté devant
les deux chambres du parlement que le
président de la république nous annonce
des états généraux de la justice
il faut dire que dans un sondage un
français sur deux déclare ne pas avoir
confiance dans la justice dans une
manifestation la police pointe du doigt
la responsabilité de l'institution
judiciaire et dans une tribune les hauts
magistrats accusent les politiques
alors dites-nous si ces états généraux
au delà du coup de com politique qui est
dénoncée à moins d'un an des
présidentielles vont vraiment enfin être
un remède efficace à tous ces mots pour
vous répondre mais parole et au ministre
en charge des relations avec le
parlement et la participation citoyenne
monsieur marc fesneau
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice ce jour d'un jeu vous pourrez
d'abord d'excusés mon collègue garde des
sceaux qui retient à l'assemblée
nationale par un projet de loi que vous
connaissez bien quel projet de loi
bioéthique et donc je veux je vais vous
répondre la première chose vous dira
d'abord et vous l'avez d'une certaine
façon dit que nous ne partons pas d'une
pierre d'une feuille blanche
permettez moi de rappeler en quelques
instants ce que nous avons fait en
faveur de notre justice et on partait de
loin un budget en hausse continue depuis
2010 est de 21 % avec un bond historique
de 8% en 2021 le lancement la justice de
proximité avec des recrutements massifs
de plus de 10% des personnels
judiciaires le doublement des délégués
du procureur le lancement de 8000 places
de prison en avril dernier pour venir
compléter le plan de 7000 lancé en 2018
en tout ce sont donc 15 mille places net
qui ont été lancées sous ce quinquennat
et dont presque la moitié sera livrée ou
en construction d'ici 2022 c'est plat je
le précise ont été programmés
budgétairement
ça nous change des percées des périodes
précédentes où on annonçait des choses
il n'y avait aucun élément budgétaire le
projet loi confiance dans l'institution
j sur porte des mesures fortes pour
approcher les français
en matière de violences faites aux
femmes avec notamment nous avons aussi
aux vrais en valant en matière de
violences faites aux femmes avec
notamment les bracelets anti
rapprochement en matière de violence
contre les élus vous m'interrogez donc
sur l' annonce du président de la
république à la demande je le rappelle
de la première présidente et du
procureur général près de la cour de
cassation le lancement des états
généraux de l'ordre de la justice et
bien à leur demande que ça a été fait
cette action déterminée en facteur en
faveur de l'institution judiciaire doit
se poursuivre en se mettant tous autour
de la table il reviendra au garde des
sceaux de décliner à l'automne ces états
généraux afin que partout sur notre
territoire
tous les acteurs du monde judiciaire
avocats magistrats agents pénitentiaires
greffiers forces de sécurité mais
également les parlementaires bien sûr
également nos concitoyens puissent venir
d'abord construire un contrat d'objectif
et partager notre partage nous ne
partons pas de rien nous avons beaucoup
plus vrai dans ce quinquennat et il faut
continuer à se projeter sur la justice
et sur ses les actions dont elle a
besoin tester les sens de ces états
généraux toujours merci bonjour d'or
vous avez raison monsieur le ministre
nous ne partons pas d'une page blanche
ça fait vingt ans de budget de l'asie
fait la justice augmente sans
discontinuer et la réunion des acteurs
de la justice
eh bien nous l'avons fait il ya deux ans
à l'instigation de philippe bas la
commission des lois est à dire
d'ailleurs que madame belloubet n'avait
pas écouté
un seul des mots que nous avions dit y
compris lorsqu'il y avait un consensus
entre tous les acteurs
je crois que vous ne prenez pas
conscience de l'importance du problème
et de la difficulté aujourd'hui je
rappelle que l'année dernière en plein
confinement des policiers fuyaient sous
des tirs de mortier à saint denis au
mois de février cette année un retraité
ne pouvait pas obtenir de récupérer sa
maison alors qu'elle était occupée par
des squatters de la part de la justice
et ce sont des particuliers qui l'ont
aidé allait récupérer et le mois dernier
les consommateurs de crack à stalingrad
ont été dispersés par des tirs de
mortiers qu'on attribue à des riverains
et qui en tout cas ont été approuvés par
les riverains l'état de droit se délite
aujourd'hui non seulement le droit n'est
plus appliquée non seulement les
policiers fille devant les délinquants
mais aujourd'hui nos concitoyens
préfèrent la justice privée à la justice
de la république
alors ce n'est pas une aimable causerie
entre acteurs de la justice qui va nous
permettre de résoudre ces problèmes
je le dis c'est la restauration de
l'état régalien il nous en sommes loin
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à nos collègues olivier
cadic
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur
monsieur le ministre
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
secrétaire d'état aux français de
l'étranger
elle porte sur la situation des français
l'étranger vaccinés contre la copie 19
dans leur pays de résidence avec un
vaccin chinois ou russes le 17 mars
dernier
vous avez affirmé au sénat que 84% des
français établis hors de france étaient
éligibles au dispositif de vaccination
locaux et que l'envoi de vaccins par la
france pour les protégés n'étaient pas
nécessaires sur tous les continents
nombreuses sont deux compatriotes qui
ont suivi le conseil de nos autorités de
se faire vacciner localement obéissant
ainsi à la politique sanitaire mise en
oeuvre dans leur pays d'accueil
ainsi de nombreux français se sont fait
administrer les vaccins chinois
sinopharm sinovac reconnu par le ms ou
avec le vaccin russe spoutnik
le gouvernement n'a jamais émis d'avis
de contre-indication contre ces vaccins
pourtant la stratégie du gouvernement de
réouverture des frontières qui entre en
vigueur aujourd'hui ne les prend pas en
compte la france les assimile aux
personnes non vaccinées et leur impose
de se placer en quarantaine durant sept
jours avec des tests de dépistage
renforcée qui peuvent être très coûteux
surtout pour des familles nos élus des
français à l'étranger m'ont alerté sur
le sujet il relaye les leurs inquiétudes
voire l'indignation de nombre de nos
compatriotes qui veulent revenir en
france notamment pour les vacances
estivales
ils sont discriminés monsieur le
ministre pourquoi cette distinction
entre les vaccins alors que l'espagne et
la grèce ne le font pas pour attirer les
touristes
est ce que nos compatriotes déjà
vaccinées doivent prévoir de se faire
vacciner une seconde fois en france à
leur recours à leur retour pour être
reconnu par le pass sanitaires doit-on
déjà incité nos compatriotes déjà
vaccinées a cherché un rendez vous sur
vite ma surdose point com est-ce que
cela n'est pas de nature à mettre leur
santé en danger
le gouvernement a annoncé avoir livré
des vaccins johnson destinés à des
français l'étranger établi à djibouti où
madagascar à ne pas vacciner à nos
vacciner que certains français
l'étranger vous crée une inégalité de
droit entre les français l'étranger
quand allez vous vacciner tous les
français l'étranger je remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et que ce
facteur déclencheur du touriste des
français de l'étranger
si jean baptiste lemoyne monsieur le
ministre devait la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur olivier cadic tout d'abord
permettez-moi déjà au préalable d'
adresser mes chaleureuses félicitations
pour tous les conseillers des français
de l'étranger qui ont été élus il y a de
cela quelques jours ou réélus et qui
participe également aux côtés de nos
postes des consulats des ambassades et
bien à la réponse et à l'accompagnement
de nos communautés dans cette période
qui est ô combien complexe alors
s'agissant de la vaccination c'est parce
que justement nos compatriotes dans un
certain nombre de pays ne sont pas ne
peuvent pas prétendre un certain nombre
de vaccins qui sont homologués par
l'union européenne que nous organisons
nous mêmes
cette vaccination et elle se déploie à
bon rythme aujourd'hui c'est 36 135 pays
dans lesquels ces vaccins ont été
envoyées ou sont en train d'être
envoyées dans des des géographies qui
peuvent être souvent sur le continent
africain ou bien en asie j'ai en tête
l'afrique du sud djibouti l'ethiopie le
népal le tadjikistan je pourrais les
énumérer et puis également 28 pays dans
lesquels nous sommes en discussion avec
les autorités parce que tout cela ne
peut se faire qu'avec l'accord des
autorités des pays de résidence c'est
évident et là nous sommes en discussion
il a par exemple notamment en amérique
latine avec le pérou l'argentine le
brésil etc
mais cela nécessite aussi un
accompagnement et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs tout cela est cohérent aussi
avec la stratégie kovacs pour apporter
la vaccination
je dirais universel quelque part et je
peux vous dire que ce dispositif
j'ai pu le l'examiner à madagascar je
crois que c'est tout à l'honneur de nos
postes de faire cela les postes font le
travail que font les préfets les ars ici
avec des moyens qui sont tout autres et
pourtant cette vaccination se déploie
s'agissant du retour de nos compatriotes
les choses sont très claires
tout français établis hors de france
peut à tout moment revenir sur le sol
français indépendamment du vaccin qu'il
a reçus après
la france reconnaît les vaccins
homologués par l'instance européenne ema
et si ce n'est pas le vaccin que la
personne a reçu à ce moment là oui il
faut suivre les recommandations de tests
pcr ou antigénique et éventuellement
conclure tout isolement
mais nous continuons à bon rythme pour
offrir ce vaccin et cette vaccination y
compris sur scène nationale pour ce qui
reviendrait la parole est à notre
collègue jeremy boucly pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes menés par le merci monsieur
le président madame la secrétaire d'état
mais chers collègues c'est la dernière
ligne droite pour des centaines de
milliers d'élèves qui dans moins de 10
jours se retrouveront seuls face à leurs
copies du baccalauréat et l'inquiétude
est chaque jour un peu plus pressante
la tension était à son compte dès ce
lundi pour les élèves des sections
européennes qui passaient leurs oraux et
non sans quelques couacs pour reprendre
les termes du ministre des défaillances
que l'on pourrait qualifier d'
anecdotique si l'on ne prenait pas la
mesure de ce que représente le
baccalauréat dans le parcours d'un élève
avec l'expérience de l'année passée le
gouvernement aurait pu aurait dû être en
mesure d appréhender ces
dysfonctionnements force est de
constater que les leçons n'ont pas été
tirées et les futurs bacheliers sont
aujourd'hui victimes de ces choix
tâtonnements absence de directives
claires incertitudes quant au mode
d'évaluation manque de perspectives
alternance répété en présentiel
existentielle dysfonctionnements
réguliers des plateformes tente de mots
qui ont inévitablement conduit à une
détresse lycéenne qui l'ont exprimé avec
force on note d'ailleurs une
augmentation de 80 % des
hospitalisations psychiatriques chez les
jeunes depuis le début de la pandémie
des choix ont été faits oui tardif et
insuffisant
l'état des lieux reste préoccupant
notamment en termes d'égalité l'accès
internet l'environnement familial ou
encore les conditions d'habitation ne
garantissent pas les mêmes chances et de
réussite des élèves les protocoles
variable d'un établissement à l'autre et
la différence significative de
traitement entre le public et le privé
ont quant à eux creuser les écarts entre
établissements autant de facteurs qui
renforcent la sélection sociale à
l'entrée de l'enseignement supérieur
enfin le grand oral comme la réforme des
lycées la machine a sélectionné parcours
sup maintiennent ce cap inégalitaire la
décision de sagesse aurait pu être
annuler le grand oral et les épreuves de
terminale votre refus d'entendre cette
inquiétude et la colère des élèves des
enseignants et des parents nous ont fait
perdre un temps précieux
comment comptez-vous dans ces conditions
et à quelques jours du début du
baccalauréat assurer une égalité de
traitement entre les élèves et rassurer
parents élèves et enseignants
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole était la secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'éducation prioritaire
nathalie bas se nomme les ministres
avaient la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur ce que
vous qualifiez d'hazard deux mois je
dirais plutôt que pendant cette période
sanitaire si particulière pendant cette
pandémie
eh bien nous n'avons jamais cessé de
nous adapter et de nous faire trop et de
faire preuve pardon d'agilité avec comme
boussole toujours trois objectifs le
premier c'est la santé et la sécurité de
nos élèves et d'ailleurs nous n'avons
jamais cessé d'adapter nos protocoles
sanitaires tout au long de l'année
le deuxième c'est la bienveillance et le
troisième c'est le prague le pragmatisme
vous parlait spécifiquement des
conditions de passation du baccalauréat
oui vous avez raison nous avons souhaité
maintenir le grand oral est l'épreuve de
philosophie
pourquoi parce qu'il faut préparer nos
élèves lycéens à l'enseignement
supérieur
parce qu'il faut conserver à ce diplôme
du baccalauréat un caractère national
un caractère solennel et aussi sa valeur
mais pour autant une fois que l'on a dit
ça évidemment je le redis nous tenons
compte bien sûr des conditions
sanitaires dans lesquelles nos lycéens
d'ailleurs très souvent et pour la
plupart d'entre eux en 2000 jauge depuis
octobre dernier avec des temps de
préparation en présentiel des temps de
préparation en distance yale et bien il
faut aujourd'hui répondre à cela de
façon très pratique et c'est ce que nous
faisons notamment en adaptant l'épreuve
de philosophie en adaptant l'épreuve du
grand oral ou encore en adaptant les
épreuves de français que vont passer nos
élèves
prochainement je vous rappelle également
que depuis le mois de janvier
nous n'avons cessé d'augmenter
progressivement le contrôle continu qui
je le rappelle dans la note finale
représente aujourd'hui 80 2 % de la note
globale
donc c'est avec encore une fois beaucoup
de braves bienveillance et de
pragmatisme que nous allons aborder ces
épreuves
nous le savons c'est un temps
particulièrement important pour nos
élèves et pour leurs parents
mais encore une fois nous mettons tout
en oeuvre pour que le baccalauréat soit
passé dans les meilleures conditions et
que nos lycéens en soient fiers je vous
remercie
merci la parole et un autre collègue up
de la ceni pour le gros du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
comme chaque année les élèves de
terminale sont inquiet mais cette année
est particulière ils ont expérimenté la
réforme du lycée subi deux années de
pandémie pandémie avec des conditions de
vie scolaire épouvante entre confinement
et demie jauge et les épreuves du bac
ont dû être aménagé et beaucoup d'entre
eux salam de l'incertitude dans laquelle
les plongent parcours sic
la plateforme s'est nettement améliorée
des vrais enfants était fait et il faut
les saluer mais des remontées du terrain
nous rapporte toujours des difficultés
de connexion et des blocs qui annulerait
les des voeux en attente la promesse à
la fin très peu d'élèves resteront sans
solution et que le but est de trouver
une formation à chacun ne saurait
suffire à apaiser sentiment d'injustice
j'ajoute qu'outre-mer les lycéens
doivent s'organiser pour chercher plus
loin de chez eux et l'hébergement
acheter des billets d'avion confrontés à
cette crise exceptionnelle
beaucoup d'élèves ont fait des choix qui
traduisent une volonté de construire un
monde plus solidaire
et une économie responsable il
privilégie les professions de santé
les formations d'ingénieurs et de
techniciens supérieurs
le droit l'apprentissage nous devons de
leur faciliter la tâche de les
accompagner avec équité et transparence
dans leurs choix
madame la ministre quels sont les moyens
mis en oeuvre pour apaiser leurs
inquiétudes
quel bilan d'étape faites-vous quinze
jours après les premières réponses aux
voeux et quelles dispositions seront
prises pour ne pas pénaliser les
étudiants victimes des
dysfonctionnements pour vous répondre la
parole et un ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et
l'innovation dame vidal vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur hassani vous
l'avais dit en même temps que le
baccalauréat et bien se mettent en place
les processus d'entrée dans
l'enseignement supérieur
et ça fait maintenant 15 jours que la
plateforme parcours sub fonctionne alors
je voudrais évidemment on vous rassurer
et rassurer tous les jeunes qui nous
écoute d'abord avec jean michel blanc
car nous avons mis en place une cellule
d'observation justement pour voir
comment la transformation du
baccalauréat impact sur les choix de
laisser un
vous avez dit que beaucoup d'entre eux
ont montré beaucoup d'engagement
beaucoup d'altruisme en choisissant des
métiers du soin et bien avec le premier
ministre avec le plan de relance nous
avons créé plus de 6000 places
supplémentaires dans ces filières pour
pouvoir accueillir plus de jeunes vous
avez mentionné aussi l'apprentissage qui
permet à de très nombreux jeunes de
poursuivre dans l'enseignement supérieur
est bien là encore grâce au plan jeunes
les solutions grâce au plan de relance
cette année nous allons essayer de
dépasser encore le record qui a été
battu là
hier en nombre de jeunes dans
l'enseignement supérieur qui bénéficient
de processus d'apprentissage vous avez
mentionné aussi le fait parfois il a des
difficultés de connexions dans ces cas
là ce sont les rectorats qui prennent le
relais et qui avec les jeunes
remplissent le dossier parcours super ça
a été fait depuis le début de la phase
et bien sûr ça se poursuit encore
aujourd'hui
pour tous ceux qui n'avaient fait que
des voeux sélectif et qui n'ont reçu que
des réponses négatives
nous les appelons individuellement au
téléphone depuis le 28 mai nous sommes
en train de terminer le processus de
manière à ce qu'aucun ne reste sur le
carreau et puis vous m'avez dit on m'a
demandé où nous en étions et bien sûr
les six cent trente quatre mille lycéens
qui ont fait des voeux c'est aujourd'hui
plus de 80 3% sur une proposition plus
de neuf lycéens en bac général sur dix
qui aujourd'hui ont déjà une proposition
jeanmaire cergy la parole est à notre
collègue rené paul savary pour le groupe
les républiques
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi monsieur le président je
voudrais m'adresser au secrétaire d'état
chargé des des retraites monsieur le
ministre les français sont très attachés
à leur système de retraite il faut dire
qu'en france c'est le pays où on parle
plus tôt en retraite avec une pension
plus élevée en moyenne je parlais en
moyenne par rapport aux pays voisins
en contrepartie bien entendu nous payons
des des cotisations particulièrement
importante et malgré tout cela ne suffit
pas puisque le déficit et chroniques
elles rapport du cor est
particulièrement édifiant quels que
soient les scénarios on voit bien que
l'équilibré peut être éventuellement
hypothétiquement être atteint mais au
détriment du niveau des pensions
alors monsieur le ministre nous
aimerions que vous nous décrypte y ait
un petit peu les pensées du président de
la république ou tout au moins ses
arrière-pensées ses arrière pensées
c'est bien aussi
et puis dans la foulée nous dire les les
pistes que vous envisagez n'hésitez pas
à nous en faire part s'il vous plaît
pour vous répondre la parole au
secrétaire d'état en charge des
retraites
monsieur laurent pietrasinski monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs écouter chez le sénateur rené
paul savary vous êtes forte averti du
sujet des retraites mais je plutôt que
de vous décoder la pensée d enzo g ou
pas et de la mienne sera peut-être plus
simple
d'abord vous dire que je tiens à
rappeler que ce qui est une priorité
absolue aujourd'hui et c'est pour cela
que le gouvernement est mobilisé
c'est d'accompagner la reprise de
l'activité et le rebond de l'économie
dont nous parlions dans une question
précédente et je crois que c'est là que
nous retrouvons la mobilisation de tout
le gouvernement s'agissant des retraites
sur laquelle vous m'interrogez
directement
nous restons convaincus et vous savez
que c'est ma pensée est maligne qu'une
réforme transformation profonde est
nécessaire pour assurer à la fois
l'équité et la pérennité du système de
retraite par répartition caf
si nous voulons avoir une solidarité
durable il faut avoir un équilibre
durable la solidarité on passe par la
transformation du pays qui a été
enclenchée en 2017
reste indispensable encore aujourd'hui
je dirais peut-être encore plus qui est
la crise qui a été celle de lakovic 19 à
d'ailleurs montré l'importance de la
solidarité lorsqu'elle est d'ailleurs
assise sur une base la plus large
possible c'est cette solidarité qui
fondent notre système de retraite par
répartition auquel nous sommes
totalement attaché alors sur les
questions de financement que vous avez
évoqué de notre système des retraites et
notamment des dernières projections du
cor il vous a pas effectivement échappé
que ces travaux qui seront d'ailleurs
discutée dans les genres les heures et
les jours qui viennent et bien montre
que nous avons un système qui est
durablement en déficit avec une réalité
pour 2020 de déficit de 18 milliards
corrigé avec 5 milliards d'abonnements
ce système
aujourd'hui est en difficulté dans son
équilibre et qu'un systèmes plus
pérennes financièrement va de paire pour
garantir la stabilité et la
soutenabilité d'un système par
répartition alors comme l'indiqué le
président de la république
récemment je conclu monsieur le
président il ya un et excuses concernant
le sujet mais pour l'heure rien n'est
décidé
monsieur savary mais aussi monsieur le
ministre pour cette réponse très précise
en attendant en attendant l'étau se
resserre 1 parce que attendre c'est
faire que le déficit continue à se
creuser c'est remettre en cause le
système par répartition et faire que les
français vont plutôt épargner que
consommer c'est faire que la reprise ne
se passe pas tout à fait comme prévu
et puis agir dans la précipitation on
sait que là c'est un déni de consensus
et de discussions et que là aussi ça
mais les français dans la rue et ça
risque également de compromettre la
reprise
tout ça est bien compliqué mais le pire
c'est de ne rien faire
rester dans le doute dans les
tergiversations et ses tergiversations
inutiles faut cesser ces sources eu
d'inquiétude 1 et il faut passer à
l'acte et monsieur le ministre vous avez
vu le fiasco dans un projet que personne
n'a compris quand même été jugé par le
président de la république trop complexe
et est source d'inquiétude donc composer
nous des choses simples dit la vérité
aux français même si c'est pas forcément
très populaire parce que on voit bien
que vouloir tout changer
on ne change rien merci
la parole est à notre que lundi viennent
artigalas pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et république
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre alors que le président de la
république souhaite consacrer sa
dernière année de mandat à des réformes
sociales le calcul en temps réel des apl
est un ratage complet
cette réforme devait avantages et ceux
qui connaissent une chute subite de
revenus elle devait surtout permettre à
l'état d'économiser 750 millions d'euros
les chiffres révélés hier confirme
qu'elle a fait plus de perdants et de
manière plus rapide que prévu et ceux
qui ont font les frais sont en grande
majorité les jeunes pour le mois de
janvier en contre 8,4 pour cent dans le
qatar en moins 41 % des allocataires ont
vu baisser leurs appels sans la réforme
le raid n'aurait pas diminuer ou moins
rapidement
faut-il s'étonner de tels résultats en
l'absence d'une étude d'impact pour les
jeunes leur calcul des apl tous les
trois mois et très impactant en raison
d'un effet de rattrapage brutal tous
sont perdants et le dispositif mis en
place par action logement n'a pas suffi
tant les besoins sont importants
madame la ministre quelles mesures
comptez-vous prendre en mettre en oeuvre
pour vraiment compensé cette réforme
comprend la parole et au belize les
positions écologique d'abord par un
pompier du dollar merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs sénateurs madame la sénatrice
artigas le principe même de la réforme
du calcul des apl en temps réel c'est de
rendre notre système de protection
sociale plus juste
ça permet d'assurer de manière rapide le
versement d'une aide qui est adapté à la
situation des bénéficiaires et ça permet
aussi la modernisation et la
simplification des apl tout est calculé
de façon automatique pour la grande
majorité des allocataires ce qui
diminuera aussi le taux de non
cours qui est beaucoup trop important et
suite au changement du mode de calcul au
1er janvier il ya eu une première
actualisation trimestrielle des droits
qui a été fait en avril
j'insiste madame la sénatrice sur le
fait qu'il n'existe pas à ce stade de
données consolidées sur les impacts de
la réforme y compris sur les droits
versés en janvier les chiffres qui
circulent actuellement dans la presse
correspondent à des données provisoires
et l'historique des années précédentes
montrent des évolutions sensibles entre
données provisoires et données
définitives
le ministère du logement communiquera à
ce sujet en juillet une fois que les
chiffres du mois de janvier seront
stabilisés
concernant l'impact de la réforme sur
les jeunes pour les jeunes actifs qui
ont un travail
si leurs revenus salariés augmente
rapidement ils verront effectivement
leur niveau d'apl diminué plus
rapidement qu'avec l'ancien système
mais ce sera évidemment aussi l' inverse
pour sedan les revenus diminuer c'est un
principe de la réforme si nous avons des
chiffres qui montrent une baisse des
appels ça veut dire sur tous les
dispositifs de soutien que nous avons
mis en place notamment par la crise ont
fonctionné et j'espère que c'est le cas
je rappelle par ailleurs que les
étudiants voir leur niveau d'apl
maintenu voire augmenté pour les
étudiants salariés dans la prise en
compte des revenus n'entrent un
désormais plus de dégressivité de l'apl
les stagiaires et les alternants
bénéficié également d'un système
avantageux de prise en compte de leurs
revenus
voilà nous sommes attentifs à la
situation des jeunes nous avons fait le
choix de modifier la formule de calcul
les appels afin de mieux prendre en
situe en compte leur situation
spécifique en contrat de
professionnalisation et cette évolution
est effectif depuis le mois dernier par
par ailleurs je vous rappelle que le
gouvernement déploie deux dispositifs
un jeune une solution sous l'égide de ma
collègue elisabeth bornes afin d'aider
chaque jeune accéder à un emploi vous le
voyez nous avons une attention toute
particulière sur la situation des jeunes
dans notre pays
madame la ministre contrairement à ce
que vous dites les chiffres sont têtus
visiblement ce que vous proposez ne
suffit pas et à l'eau et au besoin
cela confirme que tout ce que le
gouvernement aura mis en place en
matière de logement n'aura fait
qu'accroître les inégalités la baisse
des appels de 5 euros et est déjà
choquant trois ans plus tard cette
baisse est 8 fois supérieure elle a été
couplée avec la mise en
de la rls or la cour des comptes a
souligné les défaillances de ce
dispositif qui a grandement fragilisé
l'action des bailleurs sociaux tenta
matière de construction que de
réhabilitation du parc existant la
pandémie la montre et le logement est un
sujet majeur pourtant l'état persiste à
se reposer entièrement sur des
opérateurs comme action logement tout en
n'écartant pas la possibilité de
positionner encore son budget au risque
de freiner ses actions pour votre
gouvernement
le logement n'est qu'une variable
d'ajustement une source d'économie et
surtout la preuve de votre des
engagements en matière de progrès social
[Musique]
16 pour le groupe l'est républicain vous
avez la parole je suis président ce
ministre mes chers collègues qui
appelait au secours quand même les
secours pointe aux abonnés absents quand
aucun appel ne peut aboutir cette
question
nos concitoyens ont vu ce 2 juin de très
longues minutes d'attentes et souvent
d'angoissés pour se la poser j'ai bien
évidemment ici une pensée pour les
familles touchées stéphane richard pdg
d'orange opérateurs en charge la
distribution et de la continuité de ces
appels a indiqué que cet incident grave
et inédit serait la conséquence d'une
panne logiciel sur des équipements
critiques du réseau je note et je crains
que le fait qu'ils aient été d'emblée
exclu malgré l'absence des résultats de
l'anc est à la fois tout problème de
maintenance et toute attaque
cybercriminelle fat mais il a pourtant
précisé que ce service était bondé au
moins cinq fois une panne dans ces
conditions semble statistiquement
tellement improbable sauf à ce que la
redondance ne servent strictement à rien
et c'est là la première interrogation
dont je souhaitais vous faire part il
semblerait par ailleurs que la femme
n'est pas été détectés en premier par
orange mais lui a été signalé par les
services de l'état
pouvez vous nous le confirmer orange a
annoncé qu'il publierait les résultats
de son enquête interne
de son côté le gouvernement a lancé un
audit j'ose espérer que la lumière sera
faite sur l'origine de cette panne
d'ampleur et que les français en seront
informés mais cet événement dramatique
doit aussi nous permettre de voir plus
loin que le simple correctif par exemple
en accélérant le passage de nos services
publics
tout ip afin de disposer des
technologies innovantes et réellement
sécurisé quels sont donc les
enseignements tirés par votre
gouvernement de cette triste expérience
et plus particulièrement comment
expliquer qu'une telle panne puisse être
possible pour vous répondre la parole
les communistes de l'intérieur monsieur
gérald darmanin monsieur le président
messieurs les députés et sénateurs
pardon monsieur le sénateur le 2 juin
vers 16h30 c'est en effet les services
de l'état la préfecture de police de
paris mais aussi les plusieurs
départements qui ont évoqué jusqu'à 30 %
d'appels en moins que si constatée
habituellement il faut savoir que chaque
jour 150 mille français appellent les
numéros d'urgence que vous connaissez le
15 ou 17 le 18
nous avons signalé à susciter orange qui
dans un premier temps n'étaient pas
informés manifestement de cette panne
et puis a constaté pourra constater à
peu près une heure après les services de
l'état qu'effectivement il ya eu un
problème revenus qu'il ya un problème
qui n'était pas la fin du service
mais la dégradation de ce service
puisque on aurait perdu ce sont les
premières estimations de l'état ce qu'il
ne soit confirmé pour l'instant par un
quelconque rapport à peu près 30% de ces
appels soient que l'opérateur ne
répondait pas soin qu'au bout de 30
secondes
la communication s'interrompent et
devant évidemment la difficulté est
l'essence même du numéro d'urgence
très rapidement j'ai fait ouvrir avec le
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
qui était à paris lyon en déplacement
avec cédric aux mêmes jeux pré ministre
à tunis la cellule un terminal de crise
lé préfet vous l'avez vu ou remplacer
ces numéros d'urgence par des numéros
plus long à chacun des départements
puisque 80 départements et quatre cents
numéros ont été mis en place dans les
minutes qui ont suivi et nous avons donc
douze jours si j'ose dire en main le
travail qui aurait dû faire en partie de
serveurs en jeu renversé vers les autres
opérateurs qui ont permis de résoudre
une partie de ses problèmes
comme vous je voudrais avoir une pensée
toute particulière pour les six cas dont
nous considérons que peut-être ce n'est
pas certain il ya eu un lien direct avec
le fait qu'il n'ait pas pu joindre les
services d'urgence notamment quatre
décès et il ya à chaque fois monsieur le
sénateur une enquête individuel
administrative demandée par monsieur le
premier ministre à rs préfet orange a
communiqué nous n'excluons aucune cause
monsieur le sénateur nous sommes pas
capables aujourd'hui de comprendre
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
sur la base du code 2d
télécommunications nous avons saisi
allemand du premier ministre lanci et
diverses inspections pour un rapport que
nous rendrons publiques ses la demande
du premier ministre
nous n'excluons pas une attaque
informatique même si ce n'est pas
l'hypothèse privilégiée mais j'ai eu
l'occasion
ayant convoqué stéphane richard
deslandes un matin place beauvau avec
cédric au de dire l'inacceptable de
cette situation et demandé à orange ou
seulement les explications pour
maintenant mais une modification très
certainement au cours là l'un pour que
tout fonctionne
monsieur chaize merci monsieur le
premier ministre vous comprenez ceux ci
souhaitent cette cause est vraiment
inacceptable et je le partage avec vous
il est important aujourd'hui de se
rendre compte que la desserte fixe et
mobile est quelque chose de plus en plus
urgent je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue yannick jacques mais pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question à laquelle
j'associe mes collègues jean-michel
arnaud et loïc hervé s'adresse aux
secrétaires d'état chargé du tourisme
elles concernent le non versement des
loyers par les exploitants de résidences
de tourisme aux propriétaires bailleurs
monsieur le ministre vous avez été
interpellé plusieurs fois sur le sujet
pour autant la question reste sans
réponse plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de co propriétaires bailleurs sont dans
une situation impossible et impuissants
face aux différents exploitants qui gère
ces résidences sur la france entière
ses propriétaires ont pour la plupart
emprunter afin de réaliser un
investissement dans le but de s'assurer
un complément de retraite il se retrouve
aujourd'hui pris à la gorge car ces
exploitants hard de la crise sanitaire
pour ne pas leur verser leur loyer
depuis mars 2020 ils n'ont donc plus
aucune rentrée d'argent tandis que le
continue à devoir payer leurs charges
ces exploitants pourtant reçu toutes les
aides accordées par le gouvernement dont
le pge avec d'après les chiffres qui
nous ont été communiqués et s'ils sont
exacts
la somme de 32 millions d'euros pour la
partie et 240 millions pour pierre &
vacances center parcs dans le but de
renforcer leur trésorerie et d'assurer
le règlement des sommes dues à leurs
fournisseurs soit en l'espèce les
bailleurs qui attendent toujours
pouvez vous nous confirmer que vous avez
connaissance de cette situation et dans
l'affirmative comment le gouvernement
compte il y mettre fin
pour vous répondre la parole tout ce que
de d
j'ai revu tous ri puis sur le mois merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs adam la
sénatrice le tourisme c'est une grande
chaîne d'acteurs qui sont très divers
mais s'il y en a qui plongent tous
plonge et donc on voit bien que dans
cette affaire on a besoin de trouver des
solutions tous ensemble mais il ya
besoin aussi de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait du dialogue que ça se parle et qui
effectivement des solutions concrètes
soient mises sur la table pour sa part
l'état
il a fait deux choses d'une part il est
venu en soutien aux acteurs économiques
et notamment aux résidences de tourisme
à travers vous signaliez les pg e
le fonds de solidarité le dispositif
coûts fixes a d'ailleurs dont il n'y
avait aucun seuil de leur conte était
par exemple sur des résidences à la
montagne et cela a été mis en place pour
que ces acteurs puissent au dû mieux
faire face à leurs obligations
contractuelles naturellement maintenant
le choc est tel que on le voit ça a été
fait de façon inégale à la montagne 50 %
des loyers ont été versés ça veut dire
que 50 % ne l'ont pas été et c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement deuxième
comment dire engagement a souhaité
favoriser et faciliter le travail de
dialogue et de conciliation
on a mis en place et vous l'avez votée
dans la loi de finances pour 2021
un crédit d'impôt pour justement
faciliter l'abandon de loyers en
contrepartie de cet avantage fiscal
nous avons également mobilisé le
médiateur des entreprises les
commissions locales pour les baux
commerciaux et je crois qu'il est
désormais important que ce travail se
poursuit
le snrt et travaillent main dans la main
avec l'ump y qui représente les
propriétaires investisseurs également
avec la fédération bancaire française
car il est important de pouvoir trouver
des solutions aussi sur mesure pour les
propriétaires investisseurs qui parfois
se retrouverait dans des situations
complexes voire enfin face à laquelle il
ne pourrait plus faire face même et donc
ça aboutit aussi à des solutions au cas
par cas ce qui est également une façon
de progresser
donc le message il est clair il est
simple il faut que ces deux parties
arrivent à progresser à continuer ce
travail beaucoup de cas ont été résolus
d'autres restent pendants et
naturellement vous pouvez être certaine
de notre vigilance permanente sur ce
sujet oui monsieur le ministre j'ai bien
entendu tout ce que vous avez déjà fait
pour autant nous nous faisons vraiment
le relais avec mes collègues de tous est
co propriétaire bailleur qui sont pris à
la gorge qui sont désespérés et qui se
retrouvent en forte détresse alors vous
avez mis en place un certain nombre
d'actions
on sent bien qu'on est là face à une
situation c'est le pot de terre contre
le pot de fer
et je pense que tous ses co
propriétaires bailleurs ont vraiment
besoin du soutien de l'état pour arriver
à se sortir de cette situation
je vous remercie
la parole est à l'autre un collègue
étienne blanc pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole vous
chers collègues je souhaitais dans ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la défense des armées et pardo emma
ministre entre 2001 et 2014 environ 50
mille soldats français ont servi sur les
théâtres opérationnel en afghanistan à
leurs côtés ce sont environ 700 afghans
qui ont travaillé il était chauffeur
voiturier magasinier interprète ou
traducteur aujourd'hui un grand nombre
d'entre eux ont pu regagner la france et
le gouvernement leur a attribué des
visas mais pas tous et voici qu'à la
faveur de l'évolution de la situation
politique et militaire les armes et
talibanes sont aux portes de kaboul
de manière très explicite
elles ont visé ces afghans qui ont
travaillé à nos côtés aujourd'hui ils
sont dans une inquiétude terrible ils
sont identifiés ils sont connus eux mais
aussi leurs familles et nous sommes à
quelques semaines de l'entrée des
talibans dans kaboul a priori alors ma
question madame la ministre est simple
quelle est la position du gouvernement
sur l'attribution des titres de séjour
qui pourront permettre à ces afghans qui
ont servi notre pays de rejoindre une
terre d'asile
[Applaudissements]
on a pu rentrer lee merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur vous
l'avez rappelé la france a été engagée
entre 2001 et 2014 en afghanistan sous
mandats successifs de l'onu et 90
militaires français sont morts au combat
au cours de cet engagement et permettez
moi de leur rendre hommage et mes
pensées vont vers leurs familles comme
la plupart des autres nations qui sont
engagés en afghanistan
nous avons eu recours à des personnels
civils que nous avons recrutés
localement pour aider la force dans sa
mission au profit de la population
afghane et ce sont de l'ordre de 1000
personnels civils de recrutement local
les pcr elle comme on les appelle dont
une majorité d'interprètes qui ont
oeuvré au profit de leur pays aux côtés
des forces françaises entre 2013 et 2020
lorsque la france s'est désengagé
nous avons organo rag le rapatriement de
171 d'entre eux ce qui avec leur famille
représente 550 personnes en 2010 est le
présent la république a considéré au vu
de la dégradation des conditions
sécuritaires en particulier à kaboul
qu'il était nécessaire de rapatrier des
ex pcr elle qui pourrait le souhaiter
c'est la raison pour laquelle un nouveau
dispositif d'accueil a été mise en place
et entre 2018 et 2019 nous avons
rapatrié 51 expé crs supplémentaires
ainsi que leur famille soit 218
personnes de plus
au total ce sont donc 2 125 222 pardon
ex pcr elles et leurs familles soit près
de 800 personnes qui ont été rapatriés
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur
de nouveaux événements sont venus
récemment marqué
ce pays je voudrais avant cela vous dire
que le mystère de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères avaient organisé
dans le cadre des procédures de droit
commun les éventuelles demandes de
retour exprimées par les experts elle
met le retrait organisé par les états
unis et les troupes de l'otan font que
le mystère de l'europe les affaires
étrangères a mis en place un nouveau
dispositif au profit des agents de droit
local 500 bénéficiaires ont d'ores et
déjà été identifiées parmi ceux-ci 400
ont déjà été rapatriés et une centaine
d'autres devraient l'être d'ici la fin
de ce mois donc je crois monsieur le
sénateur que la france a assumé ses
responsabilités et a exprimé sa
solidarité vis-à-vis de ces personnels
qui l'ont accompagné pendant toutes ces
années d'engagement
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre
évidemment votre réponse à porte sur ces
situations très très particulier et
spécifique et une réponse très très
attendu moi je voudrais quand même
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
l'expérience antérieure et démontre que
dans un certain nombre de cas il y a eu
des contestations de visa et qu'il a
fallu devant des tribunaux
administratifs français plaidé et
défendre des cas le sens de mon propos
c'est de vous dire sur ces sujets là et
l'article l 435 le permet au titre des
services rendus à la france je parle du
code qui permet aux étrangers de
séjourner sur le territoire français je
pense qu'il faut être con lire est très
ouvert et très conciliant sur
l'interprétation des textes
il y va et en disant cela on pense tous
à ce qui s'est passé avec l'air qui il y
va de l'honneur de la france pour
apporter satisfaction à des afghans et à
leurs familles qui ont servi la france
un pays qui ne connaissaient pas ils
l'ont servi loyalement et ils l'ont
servi
de manière constante voilà je pense que
les questions juridiques ne doivent pas
constituer un frein
merci la parole à notre collègue
isabelle briquet pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
j'associe mon collègue christian rue
dansaert asie à cette question depuis
plusieurs années la poste est en
réorganisation permanente
si l'on peut comprendre certaines
évolutions pour répondre aux besoins des
usagers
il est des décisions incompréhensibles
et lourds de conséquences tant en
matière d'emploi d'aménagement du
territoire que de services rendus c'est
le cas aujourd'hui la restructuration
des services financiers nous avons
appris le 4 juin dernier la fermeture
des services de relations clients de
cinq centres financiers employant près
de 500 personnes à l'image ce sont 150
femmes et hommes qui sont directement
concernés par cette décision alors même
que ce centre est reconnue nationalement
pour ses performances et la qualité de
ses conseils
or le choix de fermer ses services ne
tient aucun compte d'éléments
qualitatifs objectif mais de
l'éventuelle facilité à reclasser les
salariés concernés
je dis bien éventuels car les les
possibilités de reclassement ne
considère ni les grades ni les
compétences ni les traitements et
salaires
cette décision semble s'inscrire dans
une stratégie de concentration
d'activités au sein de certaines grandes
métropoles
pourtant préserver l'activité et les
emplois qualifiés répartis équitablement
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
mais un impératif pour réduire les
inégalités territoriales
la poste doit avoir les moyens d'assurer
ses missions de service public confiée
par la loi une présence territoriale
équilibrée et contribuer et la fermeture
de ses services financiers se rend
serait un recul supplémentaire
monsieur le ministre considérant le
poids de l'état au sein du groupe
quelles actions envisagez-vous pour
préserver les emplois et le maillage
territorial qui ont fait les preuves de
leur efficacité pour vous répondre par
le collet
en charge du conte publique monsieur du
shop
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice briquet la question que vous
posez l'attitude que vous relayer sans
légitimer les députés sophie boudon et
bière comme qui revend tôt nous ont
saisis bruno le maire et moi même de
cette même question il ya quelques jours
nous nous sommes rapprochés de la
présidence de la poste et nous avons pu
échanger avec le président de la poste
nous a confirmé nous partageons cette
orientation que le développement
économique de son groupe ne peut se
faire sans les territoires et notamment
sans un maillage territorial dans des
villes petites grandes ou moyennes et
c'est le cas de limoges l'image est
aujourd'hui un centre financier pour la
banque postale
c'est le quatrième centre financier de
france se sont financiers va évoluer
il va évoluer puisque la banque postale
a fait le choix de transformer
progressivement les centres financiers
en centre d expertise et en centres de
compétences produits enfants gajan à la
formation nécessaire aux investissements
nécessaires dans le numérique
le président philippe val a redit sa
détermination aux députés que j'ai cités
pour que limoges le centre financier
limoges cette implantation
reste qu'en termes de taille la 4e de
france et ce même amené à croître dans
le cas du développement d'activités
notamment en matière de gestion des
titres et les valeurs mobilières comme
en termes de développement des activités
numériques et des paiements à distance
cela nécessite un investissement dans
les outils numériques
cela nécessite un investissement dans la
formation pour permettre au personnel
que vous avez évoqué les 147 personnes
situées à l'image de pouvoir occuper ces
postes ça nécessite d'organiser aussi
des mobilités au sein du groupe la poste
et ça nécessite de la concertation
concertation qui a débuté une première
réunion réunion des instances sociales
s'est tenu hier une seconde se tiendra
vendredi
je peux vous assurer à la fois de la
fermeté des engagements pris par le
groupe la poste vis-à-vis à la fois du
gouvernement mais aussi les
parlementaires et de la plus grande
attention avec laquelle nous suivons ce
dossier pour faire en sorte que ces
engagements de maintien des emplois de
maintien des compétences tout en
assumant cette transformation cette
réorganisation cette modernisation de
l'activité financière la banque postale
ne soit pas préjudiciable aux
territoires et ne soit pas prêt l'egypte
préjudiciable à l'image
un briquet pour quelques secondes merci
monsieur le ministre jean le temps
j'entends bien parce que la poste ne
joue pas n'importe quel rôle auprès des
français c'est aussi pour cela que les
élus sont particulièrement attentifs à
la présence postale en zone rurale et la
défendent
à l'heure où la crise sanitaire nous
oblige à repenser l'organisation
territoriale des activités la poste doit
pouvoir contribuer à l'aménagement du
territoire pour les services de
proximité au quotidien mais aussi pour
maintenir les bassins d'emplois
qualifiés ne parle à notre collectif qui
n'a plus chez pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition écologique
madame la ministre depuis quelques jours
la presse s'est fait l'écho des
arguments des naufragés de l'éolien
anarchique
après des années de promotion partiale
et une à l'italie amy latéral
aujourd'hui de nombreux français
découvrent scandalisé se leurrent
écologique
je ne revenais je ne reviendrai pas sur
la liste fournie des arguments de raison
que vous ne semblez pas entendre mais
vous les connaissez en revanche vous
avez reconnu que de nombreux parcs
éoliens avait été installé je cite trop
rapidement et sans suffisamment de
concertation c'est de la colère des élus
et des riverains que je veux me faire le
porte voix
ces élus ulcéré de leur impuissance et
de leur mise à l'écart face face à des
réglementations qui n'ont cessé de
réduire la participation des communes
concernées et qu' on restera toujours
plus les voies de recours
ses élus ses riverains aussi très
attaché à la défense de l'environnement
sont très inquiet du mitage et de
l'artificialisation de do sol des sols
de nos campagnes
celle-ci par ailleurs combattue avec
force dans la loi climat
désormais les arguments de l'économie
éoliennes ne convainquent plus que des
acteurs qu'elle enrichit l'engagement
pour le mixte énergétique n'est pas le
tout et aux liens et l'écologie ne
signifie pas la dictature des lobbys
face à un front d'opposition grandissant
ne croyez-vous pas madame la ministre
qu'il est temps de renouer avec une
vraie concertation en redonnant aux élus
la possibilité de choisir pour les
projets en cours et à venir
et quelles mesures concrètes
comptez-vous mettre mettre en oeuvre car
cette concertation a été muselée à coude
ordonnance de décret et d'arrêté
depuis plusieurs années il est temps
madame la ministre de donner un coup
d'arrêt à cette tromperie et non un coup
d'accélérateur comme votre dernière
circulaire aux préfets le laisse à
penser il est temps de revoir notre
stratégie de mixte énergétique avec des
énergies moins dommageable au niveau
environnemental économique et
démocratique
pour vous répondre d'abord le mobilise
de transition écologique très
impopulaire merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice plus chez vous savez
sur ces sujets il faut qu'on essaye
d'avoir un débat qui soit le plus calme
possible plus serein et de plus établi
sur des faits malheureusement vous le
savez dans la période il ya souvent des
fausses informations qui circulent et
donc tous ensemble on doit essayer de
rétablir ce qui est vrai et ce qui ne
l'est pas ce qui est vrai c'est que nous
avons un besoin d'électricité qui va
évoluer qui évolue fortement parce que
nous voulons avoir le mixte plus
décarbonés possible dans notre mix
énergétique
donc les voitures vont devenir plus
électrique nos industries vont aussi
aller plus vers l'électricité et donc
pour cela nous avons besoin d'avoir un
mix qui soit à la hauteur
nous avons une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui nous a
donné une direction vous savez nous
allons baisser notre part du nucléaire à
50% d'ici 2035 et augmenter la part des
renouvelables pour pouvoir équilibrer ce
mix nous avons évidemment des
projections à faire sur ce que nous
voulons faire ensuite
rte réseau transport d'électricité est
en train de travailler vous l'avez vue
sur différents types de 2 mx mais quel
que soit le scénario envisagé il y en a
six qui ont une part plus ou moins
importante de nucléaire plus ou moins
important de renouvelables quels que
soient les scénarios envisagés il va
falloir augmenter la part des
renouvelables de tous les renouvelables
l'éolien terrestre en n'étant qu'une
partie il y à bien d'autres énergies
renouvelables évidemment sur la manière
dont ça doit être fait je suis d'accord
avec vous il faut qu'il y ait plus de
concertation plus de visibilité que les
territoires soit mieux associé
c'est pourquoi j'ai fait passer une
circulaire la semaine dernière aux
préfets pour leur demander d'établir une
cartographie pour que sur chaque
territoire on sache où c'est possible ou
ça n'est pas possible en fonction
d'éléments patrimoniaux en fonction des
radars militaires en fonction du vent
bien sûr en fonction aussi de la
biodiversité à laquelle nous sommes tous
attachés et donc à partir de cette
cartographie nous allons pouvoir
enfin avoir de la visibilité associées
des acteurs pour que à la fin il puisse
y avoir nos besoins en énergie qui soit
remplie puisque nous en avons besoin
mais aussi une meilleure concertation et
je suis sûr qu'on s'y mettant tous
ensemble on y arrivera merci je vais
donner la parole à notre collègue jean
paul prince pour le groupe union
centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture monsieur le
ministre
comme vous le savez notre industrie
agroalimentaire héberge une filière
fraisière particulièrement dynamique
la première étape de la production
fraisière et la production de plants de
fraisiers qui sont ensuite vendus à
d'autres exploitations la production
hexagonale de plants de fraisiers est
réputée pour sa diversité et la qualité
gustative de tes produits des
producteurs de plants de fraisiers
doivent respecter des obligations
sanitaires strictes
la législation européenne fixant des
seuils nul ou très faible de maladies et
de ravageurs
de plus sa réglementation française fixe
un niveau d'exigence supérieur à celui
du droit européen
pour ce faire la qualité des sols est
très importante des exploitants français
utilisent pour cela dû base hamid seul
produit encore autorisée après
l'interdiction du méthane sodium et dont
l'utilisation est strictement
réglementée or l'homologation de ce
produit n'a pas été reconduite par lens
s des alternatives existent mais elles
sont soit plus cher et moins efficaces
soient encore à l'étude
le retrait de ce produit du marché sans
alternative risque de compromettre
gravement la production nationale de
plants de fraisiers en créant une
distorsion de concurrence avec nos
concurrents européens qui utilisent des
produits de désinfection interdite en
france
certains producteurs de plants pourrait
même être tenté de mettre fin à leurs
activités des producteurs français de
frais seraient alors contraints
d'acheter des plants l'étranger
dans cette affaire monsieur le ministre
plusieurs intéresse autant côte la
survie d'entreprises françaises l'emploi
la préservation d'un savoir faire
français ainsi que notre souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre
avez vous pris la mesure de l'enjeu dans
l'affirmative comment envisagez-vous y
répondre pour vous répondre la parole et
au ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur de normandie la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur prince où
il y à l'évidence nous avons pris la
mesure de la difficulté à laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui confrontés sur
l'arrêt de ce produit vous l'avez dit le
produit d'hamid d'abord au prélable je
voudrais vraiment rappeler quelle est la
position du gouvernement vis-à-vis de
ces transitions c'est de porter au
maximum les débats au niveau européen et
vous l'avez dit dans la question
c'est essentiel si on veut des
transitions il faut les faire au niveau
européen
et deuxièmement c'est d'accompagner les
agriculteurs s'en est laissé sans
solution alors dans le cas concret se
basent hamid c'est un produit qui est
utilisée c'est un désinfectant du sol
qui était kits utilisés et qui est
utilisé notamment depuis la fin d'autres
produits comme le méthane sodium que
vous avez mentionné
et il s'avère que sur ce produit landes
c'est ce qui est une autorité
indépendante a revu les règles
d'utilisation et qui met fin à la
possibilité d'utiliser ce produit à
partir de 2020 et je voudrais souligner
trois points face à cette situation le
premier c'est qu'évidemment nous nous
sommes assurés que le retrait du produit
soit assortie d'un délai notamment pour
l'utilisation du stock
bon deuxième élément c'est que il est
possible aujourd'hui que la firme qui
utilisent et qui produit ce
ce produit fasse une demande de dépôt à
nantes 16 sur d'autres règles
d'utilisation exactement ce qu'a fait la
belgique par exemple avec des règles un
peu plus strictes et qui aujourd'hui
permet aux anneaux concurrent belge de
continuer à utiliser ce produit est
troisième élément c'est d'investir dans
la recherche d'alternatives il ya
notamment une alternative qui nous
paraît être très prometteuse c'est celle
à l'eau aux zones et qui portait par
d'ailleurs un savoir faire et une
société française et nous voulons
absolument là aussi l'aider c'est pour
ça qu'un permis d'expérimentation leur a
été accordée pendant un délai de trois
ans et je voudrais redire quelle est la
position comme je l'évoquais ou au début
de mon propos sur toutes ces transitions
plus elle sera partagé cette transition
au niveau européen plus elle sera rapide
je vous remercie
mais aussi sur le premier ministre dans
des messieurs les ministres mais aussi
aux prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement auront lieu mercredi 16
juin à 15 heures je vais suspend la
séance se sera reprise à 16h35 pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi
relative aux bibliothèques au
développement de la lecture publique
la séance est suspendue
voilà donc pour cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
une séance bien évidemment marquée par
ce discours de gérard larcher ce
discours très solennel très fermes pour
condamner l'agression dont a été victime
le chef de l'état hier dans la drôme
pour en parler on retrouve jérôme vous
étiez aux premières loges ces mots très
forts de gérard larcher vous les avez
vécu en direct
et oui steve à une fois n'est pas
coutume nous ne reviendrons pas pour ce
marqué ce temps fort sur une des 16
questions imposé par les sénateurs ou
sénatrice au gouvernement mais sur ce
qui a marqué l'ouverture de cette séance
la prise de parole de gérard larcher à
15 heures le président du sénat qui a
tenu à donner livré quelques mots une
déclaration solennelle au lendemain de
l'agression du chef de l'état dans la
drôme au nom de l'institution il a
d'abord fait part du soutien et de la
solidarité en au président de la
république c'est notre démocratie et la
république elle même qui l ont été
attaqués a insisté le président du sénat
il y voit un signe supplémentaire de la
montée de la violence dans la société
gérard larcher appelle un sursaut
écoutez la fin de son allocution devant
la multiplication de ces actes
il est me semble-t-il de notre
responsabilité à nous élus de la nation
mais aussi de la responsabilité de
l'ensemble des citoyens de ce pays de
faire vivre le débat d'idées sans jamais
transiger sur le nécessaire respect dû
aux personnes et à la diversité des
idées nous devons veiller à faire vivre
la démocratie dans un cadre digne et
apaisée tel est le message que je
souhaitais vous adresser mes chers
collègues ainsi qu'à tous ceux qui nous
regardent
à cet instant à l'ouverture de notre
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
faire vivre la démocratie dans un cadre
digne et apaiser un appel longuement
applaudir sur l'ensemble des groupes
politiques
pas une voix n'a manqué ici au sénat
pour dénoncer cette agression des
manuels macron un cadre digne apaisé je
redonne volontairement à la formule de
gérard larcher
car le message a été reçu cinq sur cinq
par les sénateurs même si ici au palais
du luxembourg on est plutôt dans une
tradition de dialogue d'invectivés on
notera qu aujourd'hui aucune question
n'a donné lieu à un vif échange un
haussement de ton
reste maintenant à savoir si cela va
durer merci beaucoup
jérôme seller donc du débrief de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement et
tout de suite on va retrouver quand un
chalmé qui est en salle des conférences
quentin vous êtes avec olivier du soft
voit l'arrivée du soft ministre en
charge des comptes publics bonjour je
m'assure le ministre d'abord un petit
mot très rapide sur cette séquence en
ouverture des questions d'actualité au
grain et du sénat et ce message très
solennel au nom du sénat tout entier
prononcé par gérard larcher qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensé du bien et c'est
conforme à ce qu'a dit richard ferrand
nom de l'assemblée nationale c'est
rassurant dans une période comme celle
que nous vivons que lorsque le président
de la république est agressé parce qu'un
responsable politique est agressé la
caste politique soit unanime à quelques
voix dissonantes prévu évidemment mes
classes politiques sont unanimes le
projet de finances rectificative qui
arrive dans quelques jours au parlement
ce sera d'abord à l'assemblée nationale
vous y maintenaient la prévision d'une
croissance à 5% alors est ce que la
nouvelle phase du déconfinement et les
commerces qui rouvre et les restaurants
également est-ce que ça peut changer la
donne la phase de déconfinement nous
connaissons se passe bien et nous avons
des raisons d'être optimistes l'activité
reprend elle reprend avec eux des
difficultés des contraintes dans
certains secteurs et nous avons tenu
compte du confinement de quasi
confinement du mois d'avril dans nos
perspectives de croissance
nous sommes sur une hypothèse de 5%
c'est une hypothèse que nous pensons
atteignable c'est aussi une hypothèse
prudente la commission européenne à des
prévisions plus optimistes à 5 7% à 5 8
le cd eux aussi et
institut de la commission et l ocde
considère que la france sera le taux de
croissance les plus forts la zone euro
c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est aussi le fruit de l'engagement
d'états au cours des prochains mois
quand on aide l'économie quand on est
des français comme on l'a fait on leur
permet aussi de repartir plus rapidement
vous évoquez ce déconfinement progressif
mais l avant dernière phase de ce
déconfinement et quel est le bilan de ce
déconfinement pour l'heure est ce que
vous noté une accélération plus forte de
la reprise que vous n'espériez et il y a
des signes sont positifs des signes
positifs en matière d'activité nous le
voyons par les recettes fiscales qui
sont indexés sur l'activité
il ya des signes positifs en matière de
consommation les terrasses par exemple
terrasses les relevés d'opérations
auxquels nos clients nous pouvons en
avoir connaissance
il ya des signes positifs en matière
d'investissement il a aussi des éléments
sur lesquels nous sommes vigilants
c'est le prix des matières premières et
leurs approvisionnements sont les
difficultés de recrutement dans de
nombreux secteurs
donc tout ça reste extrêmement attentif
non pas fragile parce que nous sommes
optimistes et nous faisons extrêmement
attention à la manière dont les choses
se déroulent au livre du symptôme
d'alain question sur la réforme des
retraites elle a été évoquée par la
droite au jeu dans l'hémicycle à
l'assemblée nationale c'est le modem qui
aimeraient avancer rapidement sur cette
réforme alors est ce qu'elle peut être
incluse dans un projet de loi de
finances à l'automne par exemple le
président de la république décidera du
calendrier faisable techniquement c'est
toujours faisable c'est toujours
possible mais le président la république
décidera du calendrier la réforme des
retraites
ce que nous savons pour les ministères
économique et financier avec bruno le
maire c'est qu'une réforme reste
nécessaire parce que le système n'est
pas lisible avec 42 régime qu'il est
injuste et que par ailleurs il est
déséquilibré financièrement c'est
présent la république qui en donnera le
tempo
merci monsieur bien entendu les mots de
votre collègue laure entre 4 à jet ski
caddie lien est exclu et rien n'est
décidé sur cette réforme des retraites
steve merci beaucoup
quand on lit vie du soft le ministre en
charge des comptes publics un qui est
revenu sur ces 15 milliards au syded
d'urgence débloqués par le gouvernement
on passe du quoi qu'il en coûte aux quoi
qu'il arrive ce sont les mots de
gabriella talent tout à l'heure en
sortie du conseil des ministres et on va
vous retrouver tout de suite contente
parce que je crois que vous êtes avec
jacqueline gourault la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires
tu as fait la ministre effectivement qui
est en train de s'installer au moment où
je vous parle bonjour madame gouro jury
ainsi de venir répondre à quelques
questions au micro de public sénat vous
étiez auditionné ce matin au sénat avant
l'arrivée du projet de loi alors 4d 3ds
vient en quête d je ne sais pas qui 4d
mais moi oui bon on a entendu les les
sénateurs est un peu critique sur un
manque d'ambition en termes de
décentralisation vous vous l'assumez ce
manque d'ambition
ah non je n'assume pas un manque
d'ambition j'assume une loi que j'ai
préparé en consultation avec les
associations d'élus avec les
parlementaires et avec 2000 élus sur les
territoires et nous répondons à des
besoins sur les territoires avec
évidemment des lignes qui sont très nets
est très marquée de la cédante
décentralisation mais aussi de la
différenciation c'est-à-dire adaptée au
territoire et de la déconcentration
c'est à dire au plus près des citoyens
et des élus
bien sûr et naturellement également dans
un esprit aussi de simplification des
normes à madame goro vous avez été
sénatrice voulait toujours d'ailleurs en
dehors de votre mandat de ministre mais
on entend ces voix-là ses revendications
de gérin à lyncher du sénat tout entier
qui aimerait aller encore plus loin sur
ce texte ils ont fait 50 propositions à
l'été quel est votre état d'esprit
allez-vous dire banco sur une partie de
ses propositions lors d'examens en si ça
tombe bien que vous me posiez cette
question puisque sur les 50 propositions
il y en a à peu près la moitié qui sont
déjà dans un texte plus d'autres qui
méritent d'être un peu comment dire
travailler
rédiger et que l'on pourrait intégrer
par amendement dans le port dans le
texte est donc à partir de ce moment là
je ne doute pas que les sénateurs
trouveront de mon texte a beaucoup de
valeur un dernier mot s'il vous plaît
madame la ministre sur ce geste que l'on
a vu hier et qui a fait l'objet d'un
message très solennel du président
larcher en ouverture de séance c'était
important une unanimité comme sa
politique dans les deux hémicycles hier
à l'assemblée nationale est aujourd'hui
au sénat avec un message envoyé aux
primes républicain bien sûr et j'en
remercie le président larcher
ce dont je ne doutais pas bien
évidemment je crois que l'attitude
républicaine est de mise je dirais
devant les violences que subissent les
détenteurs d'autorité que ce soit le
maire de la plus petite commune jusqu'au
président de la république c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut sans cesse
veillez à ne pas comment dire être trop
violent y compris verbalement
un dernier mot sur votre analyse
pourquoi pourquoi un tel niveau de
violence aujourd'hui vous parler de des
violences contre les élus on avait
effectivement vu ces agressions d'élus
là c'est le président des pluies qui a
été atteint hier comment expliquer cet
animal relativisé en même temps le
président de la république
un failli être giflé si je puis dire et
puis il ya d'autres violences dans la
société il ya eu des questions à
l'instant d'actualité sur les violences
faites aux femmes seins ce sont aussi
des violences et donc la société doit
comment dire faire preuve d'un comment
dire la redressement à la fois morale et
idéologique pour que les violences
cessent dans notre pays
merci jacqueline gourault d'avoir
accepté de répondre à quelques questions
au micro de public sénat en direct
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup quant à un chalmé sur ce
plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
deux sénateurs bonjour françois patriat
sénateur de la côte-d'or président du
groupe lmr des pays ici au sénat bonjour
merci d'être avec nous et également avec
nous jean raymond hugonnet bonjour sénat
leader l air de l'essonne alors
aujourd'hui c'est un peu l'union sacrée
après cette agression du chef de l'état
hier dans la drôme union sacrée bien sûr
mais moi je juste donner un chiffre
en 2020 je crois de mémoire 1270 élus
agressée à la mi 2021 on est déjà à 1300
le premier d'entre eux le président de
la république n'échappe pas à la règle
est ce que oui ou non dans ce pays on va
prendre la mesure de ce qui se passe où
est ce qu'on va j'entends madame gouro
sincèrement qu'elle fort sympathique la
malheureuse nous dire il n'a pas été
giflée il a failli non il a pris une
gifle et indépendamment du but côté
absolument insupportable de ce geste là
ça aurait pu être autre chose c'est le
président de la république française
lalala comment dire la doctrine
française qui fait que le président de
la république fait ce qu'il veut quand
il est en public
cette doctrine là doit être changé il
est président de nos institutions
il doit être protégé ne pas faire
n'importe quoi parce que hier il a
également fait n'importe quoi en allant
comme ça en courant sans aucune
protection aux devants alors que dans le
pays actuellement le président de la
république on s'enlace entier au moment
dé gilet jaune qui a un fort sentiment
de haine contre lui ce n'est pas voilà
quand il est un excellent sécurité qui
doit fit finalement donné les consignes
au chef de l'état un peu comme cela se
doit
doctrine française fait que le président
de la république fait ce qu'il veut quel
que soit le président de la république
jacques chirac était spécialiste
justement de la chose aux états unis en
russie
on prend soin du président pourquoi
parce qu'ils incarnent les institutions
avant même l'homme et l'être humain
qu'il représente
ils incarnent les institutions et s'il
arrive un problème c'est un problème au
pays qu'il est qui qui survient à ce
moment là donc je crois que de ceux de
ce point de vue il faut il faut
maintenant adapter les protocoles
françois patriat vous salue et peut-être
déjà cette union sacrée ces mots de très
forts de gérard larcher
j'ai apprécié les mots du président je
les applaudis union sacrée heureusement
bien heureusement imaginer qu'ils les
responsables politiques aujourd'hui
qu'ils disent aussi bien fait pour lui
il a chargé des tirs à t'imaginer c'est
impensable
insoutenable second lieu il faut qu'il
ya dedans vraiment quelque chose de
sincère parce qu'il ya des gens qui
aujourd'hui aller partage certaines
permettent son mais à cela des
arrière-pensées on pense à ils le font
ils le font même temps le pas n'ont
jamais rien mais ils le font à titre
avec arrière pensée politique en disant
si je le fais pas me le reprocher mais
qui n'a que très peu envie de le faire
et ça je vous voyais je ne pensais même
à d'autres mais papa grain bon paquet
ensuite moi je j'apprécie l'attitude du
chef de l'état peut pas lui dire qu'il
est hautain distance et terra méprisants
et que comme il le veut parce qu'il aime
ça le président de la république
il est chaleureux il est au contact il
est tactile
il est à l'écouté moi je les ai toujours
vu même avant la campagne électorale en
2015 les colleurs qu'il était ministre
il avait déjà au contact des
syndicalistes comme ça parce qu'il veut
écouter parce qu'il veut convaincre
parce qu'il veut montrer qu'il est à la
portée des gens alors il prend des
régies accompagné beaucoup trône à la
république a dit salon de l'agriculture
à des déplacements que ce présent
mitterrand présent chirac entend
mobiliser d'autres il faisait exactement
la même chose descendant de voiture
rezaï au contact des gens donc c'est pas
nouveau et je ne crois pas aujourd'hui
qu'il est plus de haine à l'égard des
malus va compte y en a eu par rapport
annuel à d'autres à une autre époque
mais donc vettel qui sont donc changé
parce positive des accords signés ce que
je crois c'est vrai ce que constate tout
le monde
monsieur ghosn est aussi à juste titre
c'est qu'il y à une montée de violence
dans ce pays qu'il y à là il ya
plusieurs raisons qui a peut-être sans
doute la fin du coc vide avec des
désinhibitions les gens sont désinhibés
il ya aussi des gens qui ne supportent
pas aujourd'hui de voir que le chef de
l'état risque d'être élu demain et ça
les rend un peu d'échecs bas je pensais
de ces gens d'extrême droite ou
d'extrême gauche qui ne supporte
toujours pâle leur défaite de 2017 qui
voit que le président a des chances
d'être relu demain et que ça que ça
exacerbe la violence voilà c'est il ya
aussi d'autres raisons mais c'est la
part d'une autre union sacrée on l'a dit
aujourd'hui au sénat va tout de suite
écoutez la réaction de patrick anr le
président du groupe socialiste il était
au micro de quinte quentin calmer tout à
l'heure effectivement patrick hemmer
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
bonjour monsieur on entendu ce message
du président larcher au nom du sénat
tout entier certains discours et prises
de position sont de plus en plus marqués
par l'agressivité l'intolérance le refus
du débat démocratique est aujourd'hui le
complotisme c'était important de marquer
le coup aujourd'hui avec ce message en
ouverture de séance
oui un message d'ailleurs qui a été très
appréciée par l'ensemble de la haute
assemblée puisque tous les bancs
applaudi le président larcher
les mots étaient juste les mots étaient
forts il fallait avoir ce cette
interpellation finalement de notre vie
démocratique ce qui s'est passé hier est
inacceptable le présent marché était
dans son rôle de rappeler finalement les
règles d'un bon fonctionnement
démocratique respectueux alors selon les
informations du parisien l'homme retenu
en garde à vue n'explique pas vraiment
son geste
pas plus qu'il n'est mais une quelconque
revendication précise pour l'heure une
source proche du dossier évoque une
espèce de bouillie idéologique de quoi
cette gifle était le symptôme ce
président la bougie ne me rassure pas
pour reprendre votre expression
le geste a été commis peut-être par
quelqu'un qui a eu une
voilà une bouffe
délirante pour reprendre une expression
devenue malheureusement célèbre bon dont
acte
le président de la république a été
frappé et ça c'est inacceptable
un sens de chercher l'origine de ce jeu
dans l'idéologie de la personne c'est un
sens puisque ce geste est condamnable et
sera condamné sur le plan pénal
donc il faudra il y aura une procédure
judiciaire engagée contre cette personne
et à juste titre ils risquent d'ailleurs
très gros sur le plan financier et même
sur le plan donc de sa privation de
liberté et il faudra en faire un exemple
parce que encore une fois le président
la république peuvent peuvent vivre quel
qu'il soit
en dehors de contacts humains voilà
c'est le rôle d'un élu d'être contacter
le point publie d'ailleurs m ce type de
contact et je respecte cela
naturellement par contre ce qui est
évident c'est que nous avons touché là
un symbole
et je pense au travers de cette gifle à
tous les élus qui ont été agressés
depuis des années aux autorités
publiques enseignants travailleurs
sociaux gendarmes policiers pompiers
tout cela montre que notre démocratie
aujourd'hui et peut-être un tournant que
la concentration des pouvoirs dans la
vème république fait que peut-être et
bien il ya besoin de réfléchir ensemble
sur la rénovation de cette démocratie
peut être que les citoyens devraient
être plus associés est un débat à moyen
long terme
mais je vous assure que cette gifle doit
être interprétée avec quand même toute
l'importance que cela aurait l'effet
papillon on voit que ça des grandes
répercussions vous dit peut-être que à
la clé il ya une révision
constitutionnelle qui serait nécessaire
pour comme cela rénover nos institutions
et notre débat public c'est ça qu'a
derrière votre logique n'engage pas une
région conditionnelle et heureusement
naturellement mais derrière cette gifle
c'est le non respect de l'autorité
c'est finalement l'affaiblissement du
pouvoir régalien qui est qui est en
cause ce n'est pas un geste anodin et la
constitution aujourd'hui peut-être est
arrivé sinon à bout de souffle en tout
cas ne protège plus potentiellement le
président y compris contre ces actes
merci patrick kanner d'avoir accepté de
répondre à nos questions sur l'antenne
de public sénat
voilà donc pour cette interview de
patrick kahn r j'aimerais présent vous
citer une phrase prononcée par emmanuel
macron il nous dit le président il faut
relativiser cet incident qui est je
pense un fait isolé vous êtes d'accord
françois patriat de montchaude jeu
pratiquement toujours d'accord avec le
président non c'est pas qu'il ne serait
pas une surprise pour vous 2
effectivement il faut le reconnaître si
je trouve qu'il y a dans le geste
une violence est un geste symbolique
real ça choquait tous les français mais
il ya une portée polymaris non
maintenant ça a choqué les français
quand le président dit allez c'est pas
grave c'est pas grave sur le plan
matériel sur le plan physique jamais
rien arrivé je vais bien je continue
mais dans le même temps
l'idiotie attention ne laissons rien
passé ne laissons pas passer cette
dérive
cette montée de la violence il faut il
répondre aujourd'hui la réponse n'est
pas aussi facile mais alors comment ni
redditionnelle pas seulement par des
débats entre nous on y répond par
l'éducation
on y répond par des mesures on y reprend
part de l'explication on y répond par
des dialogues on y répond par l'école on
n'irait pas par l'éducation parentale on
y répond par tous aujourd'hui que vous
avez bien vu car l abandon de
l'éducation et à l'abandon du civisme
alors on pourra remonter un tout la
suppression du service militaire etc
pour été perdu avec des jet skis aux tpe
vous êtes aux affaires aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
il faut faire ce que fait le
gouvernement aujourd'hui d'à côté
prendre des mesures de sécurité à
prendre des mesures de justice des
mesures d'éducation comme le font à la
fois le ministre de la justice le
ministre de l'intérieur et puis monsieur
blanc caire on sent quand même qu'il ya
un ras-le-bol aussi générale face à ce
genre d'incidents
en gros à qui profite le crime encore
est ce qu'il y aura des conséquences
politiques assure a des conséquences
dans les urnes
les conséquences sont déjà dans les
urnes puisque les gens ne se déplacent
plus pour aller voter
je quitte à me répéter 1270 agression
d'élus en 2020 alami 2021 nous l'avons
déjà dépassé avec 1300 agression d'élus
donc ce qui manque c'est l'autorité et
j'entends françois patriat
encore une fois le gouvernement je ne
dénie pas au gouvernement la volonté de
faire quelque chose
voilà un faux sujet je ne fais pas
partie de ces énervé qui vont contester
tout et n'importe quoi ce que je dis
seulement c'est que l'état et de façon
très précise
là où il ne doit pas être en revanche il
n'est plus assez je vais pas dire qu'il
n'est plus du tout il n'est plus assez
dans ses pouvoirs régaliens
c'est un effort la justice la sécurité
des biens et des personnes et textes qui
sont pourtant actuellement respectueux
des textes en tant que parlementaire mon
collègue françois patriat également
président de son groupe
mais entendons-nous vous pouvez avoir
toutes les lois dans ce pays
si vous n'avez pas des moyens pour la
faire respecter
ça ne sert à rien c'est tout c'est aussi
simple que ça on sa patrie j'apprécie le
respect que j'ai avec mon collègue me
suis donné mais je vous donnais des
chiffres augmentation la justice où je
suis sarkozy 500 millions sur monsieur
hollande 700 millions sous monsieur
sarko sur monsieur macro aujourd'hui 1
milliards 4,1 milliards can
et dire que nous faisons aujourd'hui
trois fois plus par la justice qui se
faisait du temps de monsieur sarkozy
toutes les mesures on en prend sans
doute s'est passée sans doute faut-il
plus mais je vous donne un chiffre
aujourd'hui c'est que l'effort pour la
justice c'est par ce gouvernement en
quatre ans et trois fois supérieur à ce
qui a été fait par monsieur sarkozy en
cinq ans mais est-ce que ça va
rassembler les français nous permet de
refaire nation comme on dit maintenant
refaire nationale en plus complice pour
pour pour remettre dans le débat ce
genre de faits divers ou les faits
divers qui sont aujourd'hui journalier
coutumier il n'y avait pas il ya quinze
ans les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
j'arrive et l'instantané isation des
réseaux sociaux la diffusion c'est pour
ça ça participe aussi du fait de
l'ambiance globale parce que
immédiatement vous avez des sujets qui
sont viraux qui passent pour des
millions de personnes et ça participe
alors les gens vous disent moi j'ai vu
quelqu'un qui répondait ce matin dans la
presse
non mais c'est pas ce que vous dites
mais moi je les ai vus sur les réseaux
et les buts dans les journaux c'est pas
vérité absolue
les gens sont moins voilà il savait
partie donc il ya tout ce cas aussi la
politique les mesures qui
prise sur sur l'exagération les méfaits
sur les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui un
peu tu es sûr avec ses conséquences
politiques tous les sondages ou presque
1 sont unanimes le rassemblement
national sera en bon score sans doute
ces régionales selon un dernier sondage
il arrivait en tête dans six régions ça
vous inquiète
d'abord il est à réinventer dans la
région que j'ai présidée par la foi des
gens qui comptaient déjà 10 points
devant tout le monde aujourd'hui à 28 %
dans votre région
il était temps de le traiter à 30 et à
la dernière fois oui à dire qui est
repoussé il ya maintenant j'ai démonté
galets monter la région parisienne y en
a bien bien sûr que sa maquette bien sûr
que ça m'inquiète parce que je vois des
gens jugent jour qui disent aujourd'hui
pas je ne veux plus voter pour les
socialistes plus pour le républicain
je n'ai pas envie de soutenir le
gouvernement les verts m'ennuie je vais
essayer autre chose
héros là on voit bien il ya une
désinhibition là aussi de gens qui
disent allez arrêter de diaboliser moi
je m'explique tout ça je le dis sur les
marchés et qu'on le dit content quand on
rencontre les gens aujourd'hui donc pas
je pense que plus que jamais il s'agit
pas seulement de faire un front
républicain pour les diaboliser plus t
il faut faire aujourd'hui un front
républicain c'est ce que tente le chef
de l'état aura sûrement des gens de
gauche et de droite pour montrer que les
programmes du rassemblement national est
inapplicable qui va vers la récession
qui va dire la fin de l'état que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et que nous nous
qui appartenons au clan des démocrates
des républicains réel devons aujourd'hui
réfléchir ensemble genre hey man est
donné il faut faire un front républicain
c'est ce que vous dit françois patriat
oui alors chacun fera en son âme et
conscience les grandes théories du front
républicain on voit bien ce que ça a
donné
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit pas de
minimiser le risque du rassemblement
national
je pense que bruno le maire a fait une
erreur monumentale en disant que c'est
peu de chose avec un mépris affiché
alors que lui-même quand même en termes
de politique il ya à dire mais en
revanche vous c'est dépassé cette
histoire de fond un républicain c'est
que ce n'est pas le problème le problème
vous l'avait nommé tout à l'heure le
rassemblement national a accaparé le mot
nation aujourd'hui quand vous parlez de
nation vous parle de nationalisme ce qui
est une erreur profonde puisque c'est
aux antilles
pod ça c'est la responsabilité
politiques tous bords confondus depuis
40 ans et c'est un désastre c'est une
responsabilité collective
maintenant ce qu'il faut dire et tout le
monde le sait parce que marine le pen
dans n'importe quel débat face à
n'importe quel acteur politique de haut
niveau comme le président de la
république n'existe pas deux secondes
elle peut faire semblant elle ne connaît
rien et c'est un désastre
jean bardet là le candidat de dans ma
région en région ile de france qui parle
il ne sait même pas combien de gars il
fustige la politique des transports de
valérie pécresse ne sait même pas le
nombre de gars qui lie à dents vous dans
nos clairement il ne peut y avoir
d'alliances ou de rapprochements avec le
rassemblement des sujets à mais jamais
avec le rassemblement national des gens
mais sincèrement il faut être sérieux en
politique
je déplore que depuis 40 ans on est
laissé à la dérive la nation voilà ça je
déplore et encore je le redis nous avons
tous notre part de responsables vous ne
partagez pas les convictions de monsieur
ménard si j'ai bien compris a pas du
tout non non non moi je suis oui la
nation française je sais ce qu'elle veut
dire je suis très heureux et très fier
d'être un un responsable et un
parlementaire de la nation mais on
devrait la respectais beaucoup plus
qu'on ne le fait on va tout de suite
retrouvé jean m'a scié pour revenir pour
revivre cette séance d'actualité
j'encaisse qui a interpellé la
communauté et bien un coup de civ ce
qu'intervienne skis et ski skins que ce
qu'on a remarqué c'est que on est
vraiment entré dans la dernière année du
quinquennat ça se voit les sénateurs et
sénatrices demande des comptes on est à
l'heure du bilan de ce quinquennat et de
et de l'action gouvernementale on l'a vu
par exemple avec la question d'esther
benbassa sur les féminicides la grande
cause du quinquennat ou est-ce qu'on en
ait ça s'est senti puis on sent aussi
une pré campagne une campagne pré quasi
présidentielle dans les thématiques qui
sont abordés par les groupes politiques
on a bien vu les républicains par
exemple avec muriel jourda qui abordait
la question de la sécurité de
l'insécurité même plutôt et idem du côté
du parti socialiste avec annie le
houérou qui a taclé très fort le
gouvernement sur sa réforme de
l'assurance chômage
et puis des sujets qui nous ont marqué
également c'est un fort angle sur les
jeunes et notamment les bacheliers on a
entendu les questions de jérémy bachy et
d'abdallah hassani sur la réforme du
baccalauréat des bacheliers à qui on
pense très
or cette année vu l'année qu'ils ont
passé et la réforme du bac qui sont en
train de qui sont en train de découvrir
en même temps que nous et la question de
parcours sup aussi qu'on a entendu donc
voila un petit peu les thématiques qu'on
a retenue dans cette séance de questions
d'actualité
cette semaine merci beaucoup gens
continuent ce débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement va tout de
suite retrouvé jérôme rabier qui est
dans l'hémicycle jérôme on a aussi parlé
réforme des retraites allait oui c'était
l'une des questions les plus attendus de
cet après midi celle sur le retour
possible de la réforme des retraites
avant la présidentielle de 2000 22
l'exécutif et en particulier emmanuel
macron avait un peu provoqué un cette
question puisque le chef de l'état
évoqué dans son tour de france la
nécessité de poursuivre les réformes et
de rendre la dernière année du
quinquennat utile ça a suffi à remettre
sur la table toutes les hypothèses et
bien pour ces questions d'actualité rené
paul savary sénateurs les républicains
spécialiste du dossier retraites a voulu
avoir quelques précisions il a donc
interrogé le secrétaire d'état laurent
pietra chiefs qui écouter la réponse
nous avons un système qui est
durablement en déficit avec une réalité
pour 2020 de déficit de 18 milliards
corrigé avec 5 milliards d'abonnements
ce système
aujourd'hui est en difficulté dans son
équilibre et qu'un systèmes plus
pérennes financièrement va de paire pour
garantir la stabilité et la
soutenabilité d'un système par
répartition alors comme l'a indiqué le
président de la république
récemment je conclu monsieur le
président il ya un net exclut concernant
le sujet mais pour l'heure rien n'est
décidé
une réponse qui n'a pas vraiment plu sur
la droite de l'hémicycle on a entendu
des soupirs sur ce manque de précision
du gouvernement qui s'en remet à la
parole du chef de l'état c'est lui qui
donnera ou pas des suites à cette
réforme des retraites
rené paul savary après cette réponse du
secrétaire d'état a enjoint l'exécutif à
agir
on sait que là c'est un déni de
consensus et de discussions et que
là aussi ça mais les français dans la
rue et ça risque également de
compromettre la reprise
tout ça est bien compliqué mais le pire
c'est de ne rien faire
rester dans le doute dans les
tergiversations et ses tergiversations
inutiles faut cesser ces sources eu
d'inquiétude
1 il faut passer à l'acte proposez-nous
des choses simples dit la vérité aux
français même si c'est pas forcément
très populaire parce que on voit bien
qu'à vouloir tout changer
on ne change rien à ce moment là c'est
sur les bancs de la gauche qu'on a
entendu ici quelques contestations les
prémices en doute un du combat politique
qui serait relancée en cas de nouveau
projet de réforme des retraites mais
vous l'avez compris ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui nous avons eu des précisions
de calendrier sur ce dossier merci
beaucoup
jérôme françois patriat peut-être que
vous avez des précisions sur ce
calendrier ne lâche pas pression mais
j'écoute le débat dans l'est dans les
pensées je serai bien ce qu'a dit le
président retail où hier matin je crois
que c'était
monsieur breda tu vois ce que dit
aujourd'hui les intervenants républicain
il nous pressent dans les formes mais au
final quand même que pour passer la
tracé mais pour passer la réforme la
réforme au parlement à l'assemblée ont
voté contre
s'il ya des gens qui ont fait en sorte
que ça n'avance pas et qu'il fasse au
paseo 49 3 alors la sacu connais pas la
réponse maintenant vous savez que pour
la réforme mais là que trois paramètres
sont décelés pension soit d'augmenter
cotisation cela augmente la durée
le président avait voulu faire une
réforme plus ambitieuse plus juste plus
profitable aux carrières courtes aux
carrières intermittente avec des points
qui paraissait équitable bon aujourd'hui
ça me parait il apparaît aujourd'hui moi
je pense qu'il faudra y revenir malgré
tout ce que je pense là c'est qu'on
demande aujourd'hui je vois bien je vois
bien les arrière pensées d'un public à
te dire allez que le président yaï
qu'ils y perdent des voix est comme ça
ça nous arrangera voilà un qui a tout de
suite moi je pense que c'est une réforme
voit bien d'ailleurs le corps dit
aujourd'hui que ce serait c'est
aujourd'hui 13 milliards le disque au
lieu de 30 mais toute façon le système
est en déficit de 8 milliards de déficit
moi cela dit le corps et donc le système
est en déficit il n'est pas pérenne il
n'est pas durable il faudra faire la
réforme au cou quand donc comme la
révocation cinq ans on s'est ensuite de
ceux qui pensent avant la présidentielle
mesures allaient dash immédiatement à la
présidentielle qui sèmerait le court où
on voit bien ce que la gauche dire à ce
que la gauche elle l est pour reculer
avancer l'âge de la retraite et la
gauche et pour le recul est donc le
gouvernement milieu qu'ils aient besoin
de bons termes oui je pense en cette
matière vraiment les lavant - les ré là
près de moi je les pense que cette
réforme doit enjamber de l'élection est
porté sur la durée des deux quinquennats
d'emmanuel macro voilà donc pouvoir
jambiers qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que c'est pas fort ses dépens
la décision avant la présidentielle
donc on attend la présidentielle on va
avant il y aura des propositions y aura
des réflexions il y aura des
concertations genre à abandonner en en
jambes
la situation est simple la réforme a été
un échec
c'est un sujet majeur oui m'enfin avant
qu'elle ait lieu justement ça a été déjà
une catastrophe et un bras donc on a usé
des mini
on a palabré bref la question est simple
c'est une réforme majeure pour le pays
majeur pour la nation parce qu'elle
embarque toutes les générations de façon
solidaire où on est capable de montrer
que nous sommes solidaires nous ne
sommes pas capables
il n'y a pas de solution en mon sens
françois patriat l'a dit et bien
évidemment ans il
à moins qu'il soit devenu fou ce qui
m'étonnerait le président de la
république ne va pas à appuyer sur le
bouton réforme des retraites ou alors
alors ce manque là bon c'est en revanche
une des toutes premières réformes qu'il
faut entreprendre dans un futur
quinquennat
quel que soit le président ou la
présidente de la république et à ce
moment là je conseille à tous les
candidats de dire noir sur blanc pendant
la campagne
ce qu'il voudrait faire pour vous ça
doit être un enjeu de la prochaine ces
deux majeurs majeures d'abord pour la
nation et au sud pour les comptes
publics puisqu'on sait que cette
merveilleuse retraite parce que c'est
quand même une avancée dans notre pays
énorme et bien n'est pas financé voilà
il faut relever l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans candide paix bien
entendu si vous me posez la question
c'est 65 ans il ya aucun problème
français pas le sien il faut dire les
choses j'ai surtout s'engager dessus que
chaque candidat le fasse
64 ce sera déjà pas mal mais pour
l'instant rien n'est décidé donc ce sera
vous pensez c'est pas dit c'est assez
moyen de ma vie à moi c'était bien moi
c'est la vie parlementaire s'est pas
l'avis du gouvernement et moi je
soutiendrai david est ce que d'après vue
politique ce serait pas intéressante
pour emmanuel macron d'engager cette
réforme avant la fin du quinquennat
ça lui permettrait de marquer quelques
points à droite peut-être je pense que
ce sujet était ferme et sans risque
il est effervescents va ranimer des
manifestations des contestations savait
déjà
regardez regardez des élections qui se
déroulent en ce moment alors qu'on y est
on est des vous l'avez vu on est dans la
présidentielle
moi ce que je redoute parce que je
reviens au début notre émission c'est
qu'on voit bien dans quel climat va se
dérouler la campagne compte tenu des
éléments que j'y vois aujourd'hui c'est
vrai une campagne très difficile
peut-être même pas hauteur de ce qu'elle
devrait être
aujourd'hui donc nous n'essayons pas de
rajouter des éléments qui à nouveau à
nîmes rennes arrive
animosité dérapage dans
l'accomplissement parler sans parler des
saillies de monsieur mélenchon dans ce
contexte un jeu quand on les met bout à
bout je peux vous garantir qu'on peut on
peut s'attendre
voilà pour rester sur cette réforme des
retraites ce matin sur bfm tv bruno le
maire nous dit que le mot réforme fait
peur aux français est ce que c'est le
mot qui fait peur ou est ce que c'est la
réforme elle même dans les français ils
veulent tous la réforme
sauf quand on l'a fait les français
veulent réformer il faut réformer
il va leur rupture révèle la réforme
médias quoi le faire regarder bond et
sur tous les sujets soit le domaine
scolaire dans le domaine disait il donc
je crois que la réforme il la faut
ce pays a besoin de réformes ce pays est
encore sclérosé il vit aujourd'hui sur
des archaïsmes et une vision sur désigné
adaptation il faut réformer ce pays et
je crois que le chef de l'état a montré
on pourra le faire parce que moi je suis
très fier du bilan ce qui a été fait
pendant quatre ans non le nombre de
réformes et qui ont été votées je pense
celle de la sncf il y en a eu beaucoup
d'autres a coûté on pourrait le faire il
faut poursuivre les réformes bien
entendu mais pour qu'elle passe je crois
qui a encore plus besoin aujourd'hui de
dialogue et de la justice le dialogue on
peut en parler parce que les syndicats
ils ont mis en garde le gouvernement
contre une éventuelle réforme avant la
présidentielle ça vous inquiète
un nouveau mouvement social non mais ça
montre que ça montre que ce pays
difficilement réformable ce que dit
bruno le maire et le jody différemment
ce pays est difficilement l'adorable
parce que j'allais dire ça va pas bien
mais ça va pas assez mal pour que les
gens comprennent qu'il fasse le fasse
parfois il va mal parce que c'est un
clan contre un autre encore une fois et
ce n'est pas la nation qui est mise en
avant
c'est sûr si tout le monde se tournaient
gouvernement politique comme syndicats
parce que tout le monde a sa
responsabilité comme l'ensemble des
français vers ce qui doit être une
ambition commune et collective
croyez-moi on peut réformer ce pays nous
vous pensez qu'il ya des clans sur cette
question de la réforme des retraites est
bien entendu enfin les séries gars sont
déjà l'armé au poing le
les uns et les autres pourquoi le
gouvernement a été obligé de revenir sur
tout simplement parce qu'il sentait que
ça ne passait pas et que là si vous leur
sortait encore aujourd'hui vous allez au
devant d'une agitation sociale qui en
pleine période post gilet jaune posco
vide je vous rends garantie que la
rentrée c'est quand même quelque chose
que tous les hommes politiques de ce
pays qui soit au gouvernement ou
ailleurs on tient du bout des doigts
parce que parce que l'on sent bien qu'il
ya une effervescence aujourd'hui très
dangereuse dans le pays
celle de la difficulté de la réforme ça
a été de vouloir faire en même temps une
réforme systémique et parametric on voit
bien que sur le paramétrique y les
syndicats réformistes qui aurait pu
avancer a expliqué sa question
on voit bien qu'il ya des syndicats
réformistes qui sur ce sujet sont prêts
à discuter aujourd'hui 70 qui sait
peut-être là qu'il faut reprendre la
discussion parce que l'idée des choses
qui s'impose et c'est la raison pour
laquelle s'impose à nous qu'on soit
quelle que soit sa sensibilité les
paramètres et s'imposent à nous avant
même d'avoir une ambition et moi encore
une fois c'est bien d'avoir de
l'ambition mais prenons déjà par le bon
bout
les paramètres pour qu'on puisse avancer
alors j'aimerais vous faire écouter
votre collègue françois noël buffet le
président de la commission des lois il
était au micro de quentin calmer tout à
l'heure il notamment revenu sur le texte
anti terroriste qui arrive au sénat la
semaine prochaine écouter tout à fait
françois noël buffet président l ère de
la commission des lois du sénat bonjour
monsieur buffet un jour vous devez
auditionné aujourd'hui marlène schiappa
et peut-être monsieur darmanin sur le
projet de loi de sécurité intérieure et
de lutte contre le terrorisme déjà
adopté par l'assemblée nationale c'était
au début du mois qui arrivera la semaine
prochaine en commission
qu'est ce que vous allez adressé comme
message au ministre aujourd'hui lors de
cette audition
et bien tout d'abord fiction monsieur da
manha devait venir il s'est décommandé
mais mal aussi à passera là peut-être
rejoindra-t-il nous avons plusieurs
questions à lui poser singulièrement sur
la pérennisation des mesures qui avaient
été prises en 2015 dans le dans le cadre
de la terroriste pour le suivi du
terrorisme et la protection des français
c'est inquiète beaucoup les défenseurs
des libertés individuelles oui alors en
réalité l'expérience l'expérience montre
que les choses ont plutôt bien
fonctionné et qui on a intérêt à les
pérenniser la question de ce qu'on
appelle des me casse
c'est à dire le suivi des condamnés
terroristes après l'exécution de leur
peine
se pose rappelle que ces danses nous
avons voté il ya quelques semaines
encore une proposition de loi que
j'avais fait pour mieux contrôler les
condamnés ayant exécuté leur panier
qu'on est portée au rythme et à exécuter
leur peine
essayer de remettre dans ce texte la
proposition que j'avais faite et puis il
y a un volet qu'est plus renseignement
qui concerne tous nos services de
renseignement et en particulier tout ce
qui concerne la halle échange d
informations entre les services
leur contrôle aux restructurations il
n'y a pas de difficultés particulières
là dessus en revanche nous avons la
question des algorithmes qui est très
importante qu'il faut à tout prix mettre
en place contrôlez certes mais mettre en
place car c'est très utile
actuellement un mot sur ces moments
forts aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle et ce
message lu par gérard larcher au nom du
sénat et qui dénonce la montée de la
violence dans notre société c'est
important qui est comme ça cette
unanimité ici au sénat sur ce message
aujourd'hui c'est absolument essentiel
le débat public ne ne doit pas rentrer
dans un débat de violence première chose
deuxième chose il n'est pas nouveau que
nous voyons monter de façon très forte
la violence dans notre pays je crois
qu'il appartient à la responsabilité des
élus d'avoir conscience qu' il est aussi
important que dans les messages que nous
divulguons nous apportions
indépendamment du débat la sérénité et
le calme
ça peut peut-être mettre un peu de
responsabilité dans la tête d'un certain
nombre de gens qui s'expriment souvent
beaucoup trop vite et souvent très mal
une dernière question est un dernier
sujet d'actualité c'est cette annonce du
parti et l'air que pensez vous de ce
système de départage commenté ce matin
deux enquêtes confiées au cevipof et une
primaire en novembre uniquement si
personne ne se détache dans ses enquêtes
c'est un bon plan ça c'est un bon plan
dans le sens où nous n'avons pas d'autre
solution pour pouvoir aujourd'hui trouve
à voir
candidat ou une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle je redis qu'il y a une
forme d'urgence à se décider la campagne
est le bon oui il est le bon à condition
qu'on ait quelqu'un ou qu'on est
déterminé notre choix assez rapidement à
l'automne la campagne en ciel va arriver
très très vite
merci beaucoup mais ce fut fait et bien
ses réponses à nos questions aujourd'hui
sur public sénat voilà il nous reste
très très peu temps françois patriat
vingt textes en 35 ans pour lutter
contre le terrorisme qu'est ce que ce
nouveau texte va apporter concrètement
déjà plus récemment le texte contre le
séparatisme sécurité globale le premier
à l'antiterrorisme de colomb 4,4 texte
qui s'adapte à chaque fois à des
situations jaillir exceptionnel mais
dans un terrorisme qui durent moi si tu
peux vous dire simplement que dans ce
domaine je fais confiance au travail du
sénat pour faire en sorte que le texte
qui était l'assemblée souhaite améliorer
enrichi sur les urgences cas évoqués à
l'instant tous les buffets sur le
renseignement sur les algorithmes je
pense qu'il faut envoyer mais non même
temps il ya des contradictions
moi je pense que interdire les drones
par exemple pendant les manifestations
pour surveiller au nom des libertés
alors qu'on peut aujourd'hui le faire
peuvent dimanche tant que c'est pas
normal je vous dis comme tel genre à
moins de données sur cette question du
terrorisme même chose que tout à l'heure
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un problème de
textes j'ai toute confiance dans la
commission des lois et le texte qui
sortira du sénat le sujet il est
vraiment dans l' équilibre entre les
libertés individuelles et la sécurité
collective
il va falloir se rendre compte à un
moment donné que nos sacro sainte
liberté auquel nous sommes viscéralement
attaché eh bien il ya un moment il faut
y regarder de plus près si on veut
assure assurer la sécurité collective de
la nation je reviens dessus on parle les
mic à sancey le grand la grande
disposition qui est actuellement
débattue c'est le suivi des condamnés
pour terrorisme le gouvernement propose
de suivre ces individus pendant deux ans
deux ans c'est une bonne mesure c'est
suffisant mais moi je veux bien qu'on en
soit pour cette équipe et notre liberté
il veut qu'ils quelqu'un qui veut la fin
de notre nation doit être pourchassée et
punis comme il faut donc c'est pas deux
ans c'est pas ces gens qui ont été
condamnés ces gens tout simple ils
doivent être mis hors d'état de nuire et
ne plus être sur le sol français
point à la ligne voler quoi les expulser
vous dites ah bah quelqu'un qui a un
lien avec une entreprise terroriste ne
doit plus jamais être sur le territoire
mais après avoir purgé sa peine oui
peut-être sur ce je pense que la
surveillance doit demeurer en permanence
gens qui ont appartenu à des fins
terroristes
deux ans c'est un texte aujourd'hui mais
inévitablement il faudra les surveiller
plutôt sûr mais vous donc vous vous
condamnez ces gens d'une certaine
manière à vie la surveillance ne
pourquoi pas oui vous le prenez pour ce
qu'ils sont une fois qu'ils auront soit
qu'ils ont purgé leur nom ils peuvent
aller vivre sur le monde la france est
toute petite à la surface du globe
mais ailleurs plus en france donc vous
les ex ils veulent existe plus et de
français mais six à huit jours vous êtes
pour l'expulsion aussi deux des
condamnés pour dire que ce soit
constitutionnel aujourd'hui peut pas les
expulser comme tombait pas à le faire
aller demander dans d'autres pays sont
encore plus à l'est dans ses consignes
je vais te lis sénat se réfère souvent
au conseil constitutionnel de le faire
aujourd'hui est par contre mais ce
serait super on peut chuter de
l'association a prévu à chaque fois
qu'on veut l'échanger vous avez vu comme
ça divise il m'est donc cette mesure ne
vous convient pas mais moi je dis que
l'expulsion c'était pas possible
aujourd'hui enfin immédiatement qui
perdent la dèche la nationalité c'est
possible ces déchéances mais je crois
que la surveillance une loi de murphy
merci beaucoup merci à tous les merci
françois patriat merci jean raymond
hains ghosn est d'avoir été sur ce
plateau pour débriefer ces questions
d'actualité c'est la fin de ses missions
de cette émission tout de suite on vous
propose de revenir sur l'un des moments
forts de cette semaine de ce début de
semaine au sénat hier un texte était
examinée par les
élu objectif de ce texte mieux protéger
les librairies indépendantes face au
géant de la livraison à domicile
amazon on file en séance on en reparle
juste après